When did Chud do his stream? Oh, it's on kick, right? Or he No,
he did a regular stream. We didn't watch his stream like red
disproving what Nicholas was saying that was a lie. A lot of
that was a lot of what we assumed with no proof, but at the end
he leaked the 2.0. So, we we covered the leaks and I I realized
from the leaks that like the way people were characterizing what
was being said in group chats and behind closed doors was totally
wrong.
Like basically they're saying Chud behind closed doors was saying,
"No, no, no, no. I didn't talk about Nick at all. And it's behind
closed doors he does the same dis like uh differentiation he'd
always been doing, which is like while one specific comment was
aimed at you and obviously you're a part of the group I'm referring
to,
not the entire thing was about you. It seems to be a consistent
like rationale he uses across every every place. the Tea Party
group chat. Nicholas goes to the Tea Party group chat and continues
to complain about this. Oh my god, bro. It is like I think Okay,
me and Nicholas are done talking about this. Okay,
but then I noticed some messages in the Tea Party group chat.
Now, here's the >> Oh, also I'll just say I think I I think
I said to Aiden earlier today, what did I say? I said something
along the lines of when Aiden gets to half the size of Dickers
in either concurrent viewers or poundage like in real life then
he can call into my stream. Then I'll talk about Aiden. Okay.
I really do want to try to hold to that a little bit. Okay. I
do feel like it's appropriate for me to hold to that. >> Okay.
Here's the thing
with the Tea Party group chat. It isn't really posted in that
much anymore to be perfectly honest with you. Okay. It isn't
really praised that much anymore. I'm going to get kicked out
for this. I'm going to get called Salvo Pancakes for this, but
it is what it is. It is what it is. Okay. So, I think me and
Nicholas have spoken and that I think
Okay, already a little mark against
He'd already said he didn't want to do this before and now he's
doing it. Okay, little mark against him. He should never have
ruled out doing it before. Okay, these people lie to slander
him. He should never have ruled it out. He did try to rule it
out. Mistake. Okay. >> That's it. Right by this point.
Now, I've put out my tweet and I've spoken about the broader
issue of people not picking the story up. Okay. I've also said
on my own stream that Nicholas might talk about this and might
talk about this. >> Did Nicholas already pull him out?
I don't think so. But I do think people were using this group
chat to justify things.
So, I sort of understand why he pulled out the leaks here. And
I I looked at the group chat and I'm like, "Oh, this group chat
was nowhere near as bad as I thought." >> Okay.
Right.
And then I noticed
>> Chud sleeping on Tommy C leaking a lot of this was a
mistake. L Chud
was it? I don't know. I I don't think he really slept on it.
He seemed to go and respond. No. >> Nicholas is talking
about this again in the Tea Party group chat. And at this point,
I'm just losing it a bit. I'm like, "Oh my god, dude. Really?
Really?
We got have round ding ding round three or whatever.
Oh my god, dude. What the? So then he starts posting the most
passive
ever. Okay, after everything we've spoken about, he's going at
it again. Passive aggressive. Okay,
I'm going to go over it tonight on stream. The girls definitely
need Tom and people incorporate certain stuff. But I think the
bulk of the serious [__] is unproven. Just remember
if you don't >> Hold on. Do we need So if anybody watch
this, do we need the rationale? What did he see? Oh, Maximize.
I could just close some of this stuff on the side. What did Chud
see from Nicholas? What did he hear from Nicholas that made him
go and leak this group chat? We're 50313. I'm going to put that
in the chat here. One second. 50313.
What did he see from Chud that made him
I or sorry, what did Chud see from Nicholas that he went and
said, "Okay, I need to I'm not going to debate a doctor right
now. I know, I know, I know. I just listen, I've already said
I'm not going to debate a doctor. Certainly not tonight. I'm
doing stuff." Okay.
Uh he's
I I will look after at any criticisms he has. And if I feel like
there's something I should respond to, feel like there's something
tangible there, I'll respond.
I promise. I'm just not gonna in a real time in real time pull
a doc around my stream. I do hold that position. I do.
Was this a sudden stance he took? No, I I
I it wasn't a sudden stance. It was literally like me thinking
about this a couple nights ago, >> right? It was me thinking
about it a couple nights ago when Aiden came on and I'm like,
I shouldn't have had this guy's perms to just hop onto the stream.
And so I think it was like maybe two weeks ago, >> Thursday
morning. >> Yeah, basically
I that's that's basically how I felt about it. It's just like
not a good look for me personally
when I'm complaining about a community doing a bunch of doxing
in my Discord. But I here's the thing. I would talk to Aiden
if I if I truly maligned him and he has a good point. I'll either
talk to him or I will just like issue an apology or correction.
Okay? If he could show me that that Nicholas told him that him
and Dan Saltman are working together to take down some Discord
server or something and that they were going to sue the person
running Dioro.io.
If he can show that, if he leaks his DMs showing that, I will
issue an apology saying that he was running an op. I will I will
apologize.
I will say I apologize, Aiden. I shouldn't have said that about
you, man. >> You're already sweeping and Assam per.
Okay, so I see this and I'm like, okay, whatever. He wants to
have a little bit >> if any if anyone thinks that's unfair.
I think that's totally fair. Right, >> Ben? A little bit
of a [__] Whatever. And this chat doesn't get used
much anymore. It's probably going to disay quite quickly. Okay.
Lol. Yep. I saw that. Or wow, dude. Sweeping with yourself. Lol.
>> Well, I would I would suggest that you know Aiden said
this. Apparently, it's all happened on a call. I think that looks
really untrustworthy. Personally, that's like very weird to me.
Okay, that Aiden's suggesting this. Well,
while there's no proof and he has no proof of it, I think that
looks suspicious. So, I don't think that's weird to call out.
If he thinks that's weird to call out, he can disagree. I'm fine.
And then, no, dude. I love baselessly having an audience swung
into me. It's so fun. Oh my god, this guy is such a He's so sensitive.
It's unreal, bro. It's unreal. Like, dude,
I'm like, here here we go again. Here we go again. Ding, ding,
round. Here we go again. What the [__] are we talking
about this? But no, apparently not. Apparently, we need to keep
talking about it, bro. And I say, haha, bro, stop being such
a whiny esler. Oh my god, dude. I'm at my wits end now. I'm at
my wit's end.
I'm at my wits end with this, bro. I've already said he might
cover it on my stream. I put out a tweet that isn't actually
about Nicholas at that point. I am talking about the channels
and still he's banging on about this dude. It is ridiculous.
Oh my god. It never ends.
Holy, man. Not everything is about you, dude. Don't you think
it's crazy that zero big commentary channels have covered this?
Not a single daily commentary channels picked this story up.
So, I'm making it really clear from the start, right, that I
am talking about other things as well as Nicholas. I know that
there's been this kind of like misunderstanding or people saying
that I'm a snake. When I spoke about it on stream, I said the
big sweep might be on. Sure. That's a reference to Nicholas.
It turned out I ended up covering it. I was too soon to say that
on the stream. I then move on to talking about other people not
talking about it. And Nicholas still wants to find a way to make
it about him. It is never ending dude. It's Oh, I do think there's
a slight shift up there. A slight a slight switch up, I think.
But maybe not. Maybe Chud's consistent.
I think he was referring to Nicholas like I would say the primary
focus of that original comment of I don't I don't think somebody
I don't think people are going to cover this. I think the big
sweep could be in. I think that's like primarily directed at
Nicholas. Maybe a little bit a little bit at Auggie. Then he
found out Auggie was on vacation.
Primarily directed at Nicholas and then the next day he went
and kind of recalibrated and started talking about everybody.
Right. >> Never ending.
My single daily commentary channel has picked the story up and
then they share my tweet. Okay, they share my tweet and they
ask, "Who am I referring to? Just curious." And I say, "You,
Orie, obviously as a joke." You talked to Orgie and reported
he's on vacation by the way. Lol. Okay. To be fair, he said what
I told him. Lol. I am traveling for a couple of days right now.
This is the whole Becket issue that Dioro has a reason to be
upset at Chud said what Chud said because they are friends and
it means so much more the way Chud is saying it now. Yeah, that's
the big call out Nick is mad about. Okay, but they weren't friends.
Nicholas was totally snaking Chud the whole time.
Nicholas is a total snake, right? Nicholas is literally the second
Chud doesn't call Nicholas like that weekend or whatever that
end of May weekend or week. The second Chud doesn't call him,
Nicholas goes to uh what do you call it? VidCon, right? And starts
talking about Chad Dole as friends. So I what are we what are
we doing here? Like that's not that's not I kept the line of
communication open. That's not oh we're still friends. That's
I'm I'm literally presenting the facade of a friendship and rat
you behind the scenes.
Right. Obviously,
>> Sensy, Brio, more Pegasus, WestJet. So, just some names
off the top of my head of the kind of channels I haven't picked
this up. Okay, say their names then. Name a daily slot channel
because your chat only sees me lol. Sorry, Nicholas. Who's afraid
of chat again? Who is it that's afraid of chat? You're there
quivering in the Tea Party group chat. Oh, that Hold on. That's
an awesome point though that I don't think I brought up that
I should have brought up actually
when I read these.
Nicholas is the person consistently saying, "Chud, you're afraid
of your chat. Chud, you're afraid of your chat. Chud, you're
afraid of your chat." And he is consistently moaning about Chud's
chat coming after him. Hey Nicholas, sounds like you're afraid
of his chat. And he has no problem with them.
very deceptive, Pigas. Very deceptive. worried that my chat is
only going to see you and I'm the one that's afraid of chat.
You
>> you [__] [__] bro. What a [__]
pathetic coward, man. Sat there acting all [__] tough
on his stream with his dry [__] mouth and his little
gasps, sweating like [__] knowing that I'm not on
[__] holiday anymore, okay? And I'm here to [__]
respond to your [__] And here you are weeks ago.
Oh, but your chat is only going to see me. You
get, bro. Get your drooling audience is gonna go, "Oh, this doesn't
mean anything. This doesn't mean anything." Yes, it does, bro.
I'm exposing that you're the one that's terrified of chat. Actually,
not me. You're the one sat there complaining to me that my chat
is going to see you because I've not made it clear enough that
it's not about you.
And it isn't actually about you. It's very clear when you read
the tweet that it's not about Nicholas cuz I talk about the
Oh, hold on. What's this guy saying? In transcendental. I would
expect that Nicholas is doing this to everyone else behind their
backs as well. I'm sure he's got people heal to. I'm sure he's
got people he to etc. I actually disagree there in transcendental
because he doesn't have more meaningful valuable relationships.
So, he's probably not the most valuable relationships he has
because other people would be incentivized to go behind his back.
I disagree on that part, but we'll see what the rest of what
she said is. He also consistently sends his own chat around to
every video that mentions this drama since it started. Yeah,
not shocking there. I'll do Leaflet right after this. I'll do
Leaflet right after this. I'm gonna do a little bit of this because
I don't want to miss out on this and I do need to cover it and
I think the Leaflet stuff could carry on to later in the stream.
Okay. Been a Chud viewer for almost four years and I literally
never felt compelled to act on his behalf like that.
Sure. I don't think Chud sends anybody anywhere. Nicholas is
literally mad at Spicy Chat. This is the same thing that happened
and it's so funny and I I make this point and maybe nobody else
finds this compelling but it is Nicholas goes out of his way
to say I thought Chud was principled because of the DK editing
issue. I thought Chud was principled because of how Chud Chud
stood because of how Chud stood by his editor DK when Destiny
like wanted Chud to fire him. I thought that was so noble. And
so I I decided to team up with Chud and we're going to move on
together.
Well, the reason Destiny was doing that is because he didn't
like what Spicy Chatters, namely like chiefly DK, were saying
about him. And that's the reason Destiny went after Chud because
DK was obviously thought Destiny was a human being. Consistently
criticized the guy, consistently criticized him cheating with
Lauren Southern,
made fun of the mental spiral that sent Molina into Destiny's
ex-wife, right? And so Destiny didn't like DK talking about his
personal business and intervened and said, "Hey Chud, you need
to fire this guy." Got his friends and there's a whole thing
like basically saying, "You have to go and get rid of this guy."
And Chud said, "No, I'm not doing that. No, that's up. I'm not
doing that." Nicholas liked that when Chud resisted saying, "Oh,
you don't like that this guy's like hitting your ego? This guy's
pointing out things you did? Too bad. I'm not firing him." And
now Nicholas is like, "I really don't like that your audience
says mean things about me. That's the crux of the the the problem
here. Your audience says mean things about me and I hate it and
I'm I'm cutting you off. You're out of here. You're done. You're
out of the house, buddy. You're out of the house."
And it's like, dude, how are you different? What is the the difference
between you and Destiny here? I don't know what the difference
is other than that like Destiny never bothered to make as big
a deal directly with Chud. He made it about DK, about the people
who were doing the actions. You don't even have the courage to
do that.
You know, it sounds embarrassing when you go after chatters,
but that's what you're actually upset about. And these chats
kind of prove that out. You're actually upset about spicy chat,
right? And it's the same problem. Spicy chatter's not having
a favorable opinion of you. You have that causing a rift between
you and Chud and then you being okay with your surrogates talking
about Chud in the interim. It is the same. It's the same abstract
problem repeating again. And Nick has the gull to cite the spicy
chat thing, the original drama with Destiny that caused Chud
to leave and say, "That's what made me respect Chud."
Okay. And what would make you respect him here? Just taking your
load on his chin and saying, "Thank you, Mr. Dawn. Thank you,
Mr. Dawn. Thank you very much, Mr. Don. May I have another?"
No. The Daily Slop channels
in the tweet because you know what? I am trying to make it clear
that there are bigger people here than Nicholas and Ogie that
are not picking the story up. Okay?
And still he's trying to make it about himself. He's trying to
make it about himself again cuz he's a total
bro and he cannot see past that. And he's quivering that my tweet
doesn't say this is not about Nicholas Dioro by the way. [__]
me, dude.
Oh, sorry dude. I'll make sure to say things in such a way so
you never get
dick. This is what he wants. This is what he wants.
He wants a little proviso. This is not about Nicholas Dorio.
Chudlo logic chat. Nicholas Dioro is worried about you. He's
anxious about you.
He's nervous. Please don't give him any ple please don't ag
Oh my god, bro. Okay, that's an explicit That's an explicit call
to action. That's an explicit call to action to go in to go after
this guy. Come on, man. What the [__] >> Holy
[__] man. If you mention Asan Pike or Idubbbz, then
you're clearly talking about me to 99% of your audience.
>> No, the whole thing with the DK thing was I think it's
it's actually very similar to the Pisco thing where it's like,
what do you think is required of me that is not required of you,
right? What are you willing to commit to? Sorry. What what what
do you want me to commit to that you wouldn't be willing to commit
to yourself?
That's like broadly what it comes down to, right? Like do you
want me you want me to go and tell people like to stop talking
about you? You want me to like there's Oh, maybe maybe it's not
just that, but that's that's a part of it. And then do you want
me like do you really want me to go and tell these people? Do
you think I have the power to go and tell these people, hey,
you have to like
Do you think I really have that power? Do you think I really
have that? Can I do that? Can I go and say, "Hey, actually be
nice to Nicholas."
>> Wow. That's interesting, isn't it? Nicholas has banned
so many people from his chat that they've come to my chat and
now his audience is captured by my chat and he's worried about
my chat. That's what's going on here. That's what's going on
here, dude. Let's be real. Let's be real for a second. Okay,
dude. I spoke about I spoke at length about this today, which
is true, by the way. Okay, people thought I was doing this cowardly
thing. Well, actually, look, I wasn't talking about Nick. Now,
I can say I could have been clear about it, okay? But absolutely,
I was making a broader point and I was in that tweet that there
was a hesitancy to talk about the story, okay?
To be fair, Chad, even I thought you were talking about Nick
and I haven't spoken to him in a long while. Okay, well, whatever.
Who cares what [__] guy thinks? Bro, you're so sensitive.
I said you might talk about it.
The problem is people don't care if these guys sweep and never
call them out. So, sorry. Also, I do want to apologize to Ogie.
Actually,
I am sorry having to do this. And to be honest with you, I'm
sorry to everyone else in the group chat. Okay. I don't want
to have to do this. I don't want to have to do this. Okay. But
my hand has been forced. >> I figure we get everything
on the table. >> I'm just going to say it. Augie looks
good in this entire this entire sequence. Auggie looks great.
Auggie sitting here. He's not arguing like you should just be
loyal to Nick. He's going, "Hey, I think like factually this
is the way I see it. If you disagree, you could argue with me.
Hey, factually, this is the way I see it. If you disagree, you
could argue with me. By the way, I've made all of the same points
Auggie made in this group chat. Every point Auggie made in this
group chat is for why or like the same reasons I think nobody
had made a video yet. Like, I think there's you're making Hassan's
bad content. A lot of those channels. So, when you say like,
"Oh, well, what if this was about Hassan? You would have made
a thing." These people aren't even attempting to be journalists.
These people are total scum. They are total scum. They're not
attempting to be fair or or pick up whatever stories. They built
an audience based on going after somebody. That's all they want
to do. Okay? That's they they just want to stay in that lane
all the time. >> Then everything's out in the open. Okay.
The problem is people don't care if these guys sweep and never
call them out for that kind of stuff at all. Whereas me and Nick
historically get endless for sweeping. So I don't blame >> Oh,
by the way, that's um these creators. That's these creators.
Not Not even I'm not even talking about Nick here. I'm not even
talking about any of the commentary like these guys. I'm talking
about these people. They all have like a niche carved out. They're
not trying to be fair. They're not trying to be nuanced. They're
not trying to be journalistic. They're just >> Nick for
integrating your callouts being directed at him and me, bro.
you see you see the problem here with Ogie, bro. He's having
to like prop up Nicholas's aic behavior because he knows what
the consequences are if you go too far against him. It's so obvious,
bro. It's so obvious, dude.
Oh my god, dude. Dude, I get it, Augie. I understand. I know
what it's like to be in an abusive relationship with Nicholas.
It's fine.
Nobody thinks you're talking about Gito. And if you want to draw
that >> Aiden crashed out. Okay. >> Distinction.
You should be more clear interpreting.
Also, Orgie, if you have an issue with me mentioning you away,
I apologize. I was just highlighting that you weren't around
to talk right now. >> I don't.
Okay, then why isn't it bringing up >> dude? Uh I think
Auggie is in like the toughest position of anybody here. And
I think he handles it very well. Okay. He's he's actually in
a really tough position. He handles it perfectly. He just, by
the way, I think there it's possible he's biased towards making
those factual arguments. I believe a lot of those are the case.
Like these guys are just operating within their algorithm. They're
purely algorithmic channels. The Tom stuff doesn't really fall
within their algorithm.
Maybe maybe he's pushed by bias to make that argument, but at
least he's finding a factual argument that you can stand behind.
I believe that personally. I don't know if he I don't know if
it's bias or just his reasoning that pushes him there, but yeah,
it's awesome. It's awesome that he's not just being a [__]
and going, "You're friends with me. Why would you do this? You
stabbed a knife in my neck. You stabbed a dagger in my neck,
man." >> I said that because he's talking about the cabal,
not covering it, but mentioning Orgie is away. Oh no, Nicholas
might be getting more because I mentioned that or is away. Do
you see the insanity here, bro? It's wild. He just is so desperate
to like not be in any sort of limelight with this. Even the fact
I've mentioned that or away apparently is some terrible thing
when >> Oh, by the way, also I should add uh I could totally
call Chut out and say that if he let's say him and Nicholas had
like reconciled this morning. This never happens. Like this obviously
never happens. There is a factor here that is the fact that they
they didn't they had the like going the separating of ways that
morning when the turkey tom stuff comes out that night, right?
that I don't I think there's absolutely some you know what is
it uh there's some animosity there Chud knows that he can go
after this guy that like he feels like you he he feels I think
justifiably he probably senses like this guy's not been working
towards a resolution and he thinks you and he acts out you
and I think he's justified but I I do think it's like it's petty
in its motivation it might be justified but it's petty in its
motivation more then I'm justified in doing it. >> The
reason I'm saying it is to say to be fair to Augie, he's not
>> I know some people I know some people could disagree
with that. I understand how they could disagree with that.
I disagree with disagreeers. There's some petty element here
where obviously the fact that they just had this thing where
Nicholas says, "Good luck with whatever you're doing over there."
Where Chad's like, "Oh yeah, good luck with whatever I'm doing
over there. You're supporting a night like jokingly not actually
accusing Tom, but just like huh you look at this grenade you
have to deal with,
I think it's anybody who disagrees with that. I think you're
>> co. He said he's going to cover up on his back. That's
the whole point of me saying that. Okay. I don't know. But I
wasn't bothered about that.
Just supporting that you're vape posting is just directing more
at me. Someone who quite literally isn't skipping a stream to
cover it. Dude, he is so bothered about getting And here's the
problem, Nicholas. It's not just me. I said the big sweep might
be on. Okay. Meanwhile, Kiwi Farms is calling him some sweeper.
Okay. You've got all of the anti-commentary people that are floating
about. They're getting into the mix. They're calling him a sweeper.
All the kind of technicals era people are talking, you know,
the double standard stuff. You know, people are getting the boot
in. It's not just for me and it's not just for my community.
But because I'm making other points about people not picking
the story up, it becomes all my problem. Dude, do you see, dude?
I just hope you can at least see
how hard this is to deal with this guy, man. I'm the problem
apparently and this is what you're dealing with behind the scenes.
>> So I think Chud does make a very Chud is in a secret
location. Chud hiding in the attic. He knows He knows Cabal assassins
are combing the streets of whatever little London hamlet he lives
in. Okay. Looking for this guy. This guy is not leaving his house.
He's in the bunker right now. Okay. He's actually got Stylo standing
at the door. He's in the bunker.
No commentary assassin will get past Stylo. Okay. So, I think
with Chud with Chud
right now,
I I totally get where he's coming from,
I just It's
just what what he's uh I I think it's
when people are so two-faced like this and then they accuse you
to hide their duplicity. They accuse you of being duplicitous.
That's that's what's always to me is like I can tell I can tell
that Nick is being duplicitous because I've seen it happen before
and I
how do I put it? I can tell that there are other people who are
getting information from like another source and I'm like man
this doesn't really sound like Nick. Nick was like having someone
talk [__] about him and he just totally refused to
engage. He wouldn't talk any of this guy behind the scenes. That's
not what I've heard. That's not what I've seen ever. And I've
seen a little bit of Nick talking behind the scenes. Who's Nick?
Nicholas Dioro. This guy right here. Nicholas Dioro. Big Twitter
guy, big YouTube guy, huge Ethan Klein.
Holy [__] dude. It [__] crazy, man. Yeah.
Um, some post I was taking a shot at you on your gay subreddit.
I literally looked and saw no videos other than mine about it
apart from the It's nuts. I was referencing the YouTube drama
post as the coverage. I feel like I'm going insane. Maybe you
should be a bit less sensitive when all these chats send you
on a one comment death spiral. Oh my [__] god, dude.
Oh my god.
I'm the sensitive one apparently. Whilst he's in here again arguing
about this again, hyper sensitive about being referred to at
every stage. I mean, come on. You defin somewhat maybe not 100%
nickel or me and Percy, I don't care, but it feels like gaslighting
for you not to admit you're chewing clowning on us for sweeping.
I made comments on stream talking about the status of where you
guys are on what you said because bear in mind by this point
I have streamed I think on kick. I think I streamed on kick and
I said going to talk about it and Nick said he's going to talk
about it. Okay. I looked this
>> Thank you. >> Going live to about this while blocking
every chhatter who disagrees is why I think he is going to be
loa of
27 by now. Nicholas is going live. Oh my god. There's no way
dude there's no way. What's the problem? What's the issue here?
What's the problem, dude? We're just chilling. We're just putting
all We're just putting it all on the table. What's the problem?
>> Did Nick respond anymore or did Nick like um cuz I think,
how do I put it with Nick? He did the first response, then he's
like, I won't respond to this again. And I do feel like this
tangibly changes so many things
that I do wonder how he could justify not responding again because
I think his his sweepers have kind of been like
and I don't say sweepers like I I like Becket. I think Beckett's
basically been convinced of
some facts that aren't
right? I think I think >> you can call in if you want.
We can have a chat about all this. We can have a chat about all
this dude.
No time to go live for an emergency stream of Tom's allegations.
Time to go live now, dude. Oh my god, dude. What's the stream
title? What's the stream title, though? What's What's the stream
tit?
Oh, guys, there's a new Idubbbz video.
Idubbbz is lost again, guys. Idubbbz is lost again. Come on,
STOP WATCHING CHAD. HE might reveal something I don't want you
to see. Come watch me talk about Idubbbz, loser. Get
revoked. I'll give you one chance, okay? Okay. And I'll just
remind everybody at this point in the stream, it will be a timeout
for the night. And you can sub, you can give five subs if you
want to talk about the hockey game, you can give five subs if
you want to do that. Okay?
If you want to come back when I time you out for tonight, you
refer to the hockey game. Five subs. Okay. Great, bro. Good luck.
[__] O piggy. Oink oink. The slop's up to serve.
You little piggy.
Oh my god, dude.
I've made comments on stream talking about the status of where
you guys are on what we have said. I looked this morning at what
videos were out and it was mine and cam nuggets. Then I posted
that. I knew that you were both possibly going to cover it. I
knew that you were both possibly. So this is genuine. I'm genuinely
saying that was about these other not covering it. I know you
guys are going to cover it or possibly going to cover it. So
I'm talking about them now. But they're still finding it a way
to bring it back round to themselves. It's so obnoxious, bro.
Why do you think so few people have covered it? The story is
just forming.
You started talking about the big sweep in your stream on Thursday
morning after the shot to Wednesday night. I was talking about
the big sweep might be on. These things take a while to take
root. Glad you cleared it up half ass today though. Oh my god,
dude. Dude, bro,
dude, everything is about clear up, >> It's only fair you
read all of Nick in a dumb whiny voice like he did for you. Taste
your own gay medicine. F.
>> Thank you. though you're the sport.
Glad you cleared up half ass today, though. Give me a [__]
break with that. These daily commentary channels pump out slop,
dude. Do you know what I love about this? Nicholas releasing
DMs that show nothing. Oh, so base. So cool, King. Well done.
Me releasing DMs further showing what a pathetic, sensitive coward
this guy is. Oh, this is a nothing, dude. Hayden, I'm I'm not
watching any of these clips. If you guys want to tell me what
happened, I'm totally fine with it. I I'm like fine with it.
I literally it's it's like I'm I don't really want to fight.
I don't want to I don't want to attack Aiden.
I just
the thing with the Dioro thing and the like talk about the servers
and stuff. That seemed very weird to me.
And then he said he didn't like record it or whatever, which
is whatever this one thing. Okay. I I don't want to push this.
I don't want to make this guy spiral. I'm just I'm not This is
embarrassing for you. as he sat there quivering in chat, moaning
about my community, moaning about my audience not understanding
and thinking it's about him. You dude, [__] you.
So anyway, I'm I'm saying these things take. I'm actually responding
to Augie here. Give me a [__] break with that these
daily comments channel. >> This is this is the thing I
said somewhere else. I'm like, dude, if he's actually like like
spiraling or
I'll just retract whatever I said. But I I still think it's weird.
It's just like I'll retract whatever I said about the SC up or
something. I just It's just weird to me that he would have this
information that Nick categorically denies. Aiden can't prove
it at all. It seems like I
>> Okay. Um
that's that's what I think.
>> That's what I think. And if anybody disagrees with that,
I'm perfectly happy to discuss that. Uh Black Ice, thank you
for the five gift, dude.
Anyway, I think that's fine. pump out
daily commentary talks about KSI and Logan Paul who is doing
daily Kiwi Farm slop or making any content that this would fall
into the usual docket.
So I use more Pegasus as an example. Okay,
this is what I'm talking about man. What ties does Pegasus have
to Tom that he would not end up covering this? What incentive
does he have to sweep? So this gets into the kind of intricacies
of it. Okay, this gets into like the intricacies of it and it
could be and me and talked about this, right? It could be
it could be that maybe it's too profitable talking about Assan
and Idubbbz. Okay. So maybe that's the reason it doesn't get
spoken about but then it still is not bringing attention to an
allegation which again not saying Tom's guilty but the nature
of that dynamic means that it doesn't end up getting spoken about.
Right. >> Nick ended up accidentally muted for the first
two to three minutes of the stream because he missed everyone
telling him because he was ignoring his chat because it was blowing
up about Chud. Very >> It could be that they're friends
with him. It could be their friends behind the scenes. Here's
the thing, right? You need to look at the way that the response
was dealt with to see that I was correct. Everyone was on the
response like white on rice. It was within like a day. Everyone
was on top of it. Even people that didn't cover the allegations
originally.
Okay.
When the came when the allegations came out, it was not sure.
Not bit of hesitancy. Bit of resistance.
Bit of resistance. Two are talking about it. There's nothing
wrong with making content allegations as long as you notice it
is an involving story. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. And then we kind
of go backwards and forwards about, you know, this stuff. This
doesn't look unusual to me. He covers mainstream topics.
Turkey Tom is not a mainstream topic right now. It could be,
but this kind of lack of coverage does not seem abnormal to me
at all. In fact, knowing Pegasus and how these daily guys operate,
they pick stuff that's as safe and norm as possible. Tom is neither
of those things. Yet, it could become that. Okay.
Just seems insane to me that if Assan or Idubbbz had this exact
same thing happen to them, we would already have 20 videos from
daily slot channels. So this is me posting this saying, look,
I'm talking about daily slot channels here. I'm being quite clear
that I'm talking about daily daily slot channels. And then
Rational Chad, I would say if commentary people are not covering
it by tomorrow, then I think you could give some sweet criticism.
But isn't all this like brand new? Gets ignored obviously. Don't
worry, mate. It's just banter in it. This guy is so pressed,
bro. H Yeah, you guys can't take a bit of banter. Okay.
And then and then all he says, look at this. Isn't this Isn't
this crazy?
Isn't this crazy, dude? Isn't this crazy? By the way, I'm more
than happy. I wonder if Becket ever watched this. He wouldn't
go past a certain point earlier when he when this is explained.
It was very
Oh, wait. Did Becket go over some of Chud's stream?
I talked to Beckett about it again, but I need to see what he
said
because I I feel bad because I said um I said Becket was referring
to this group chat. I thought he did that in a in the conversation
we had, but if he didn't do that in the conversation we had,
then I misremembered.
So, I'd have to give that to Becket as well.
Right.
>> I thought I thought Becket referenced this group chat
in the conversation we had that said like Chud's inconsistent.
He was inconsistent in the group chat.
No. Am I crazy? >> When we talk on stream, so we'd already
Yeah, sure, man. Sounds good. Like, look at the difference, bro.
Me and we're also going I will not leak obviously my own DMs
with I feel a bit bad about including here, but has been more
than reasonable in this. Okay,
we've talked, we've argued,
you know,
it's been great. It's been great. It's been great, but not so
with Nicholas, unfortunately. And then Keem started some other
stuff.
Um, I won't really be live till Monday or Tuesday now. So, I'm
having to take the weekend off and then we talk a bit they talk
a bit about what the allegations are from here. Okay. Okay.
Um, I watched half a cam nugget video corner dropping. So, I
was going to watch that and then maybe scroll the dot myself
to get filled in. Also, man, you have to appreciate that there
are a lot of there's a lot of hate coming your way
already. People are jumping off my tweet to mention you like
Alberto is not even in my community. So, I noticed that people
like Michael Alberto were kind of commenting on the post and
um it's like Michael Alberto isn't really from my community.
It's not like he's in my chat. It's not like he watches my streams,
but there's like this kind of anti- commentary
like people, right? These anti- commentary people that are also
sniffing about this, you know, and just to be clear, I don't
have like a massive beef with Michael Alberto, right? I'm just
using him as an example, you know? This is not said with any
malice. I'm not saying this is like, you know, it's literally
just look, there's other people that really don't like you that
are also jumping off of this and he's like trying to make out
like it's all me, you know.
Not to beat a dead horse, but how the Boax let Connor beat him
to the story again? Lol.
Okay.
Dude, look at this as well, dude. Look at this too. Look at this
too, dude.
You seriously telling me that it isn't wild that 48 hours after
one of the biggest commentary guys, allegations that drop that
all over Twitter, there isn't a single large channel talking
about this? Who do you think I'm talking about here?
Am I talking about Nicholas?
Am I talking about Nicholas or am I talking broadly? Am I talking
about Israel? There's no big channel talking about this, right?
And what does Nicholas do? What does Nicholas do? Makes it all
about himself again, bro. All about himself again. It's just
Wednesday evening is not 48 hours. Even if I covered it yesterday
on my day, on my off day, my VOD wouldn't be out until Sunday
after EAP Saturday.
Dude, I'm not talking about you. I mean broadly.
I mean broadly
because I'm talking broadly. I understand Nicholas is not covered
yet. He's a streamer. The Daily Slo channels, it takes an hour,
two hours to make a video and they've not got a video out yet.
Isn't that weird? Isn't that odd? Isn't that a bit I still don't
think this is a good argument. I think this doesn't fit in with
their algorithm. If they didn't have a video going out that day,
maybe it works. But I do think it doesn't fit in with a lot of
the stuff they do regularly. Like a lot of these guys are vaguely
like migtau vaguely like a a story where you're going off vague
allegations from a woman. I do think it works against like the
algorithm they've worked themselves into. I I do so I I do think
there's a lot of reasons they wouldn't cover it actually. >> But
no, Nicholas wants to make it about himself again because of
his [__] victim complex. Holy I'm talking about the
Daily Commentary channel.
>> As an answer to your question, the reason the Daily
Guys aren't posting is cuz one person hasn't researched it yet.
All those guys steal from each other. Once a video is dropped,
it cascades.
Yeah, and people don't want to go near it because it's Turkey
Tom. Fair enough comment, I think. Dude, I even said I have some
sympathy for not wanting to light your friend up. It feels like
you were looking at all the takes and most provocative clips
and thinking it is all about you. I was fair to lean on the meme
to lean on the little meme there. Okay, it's only fair. It's
only fair to lean on the meme there. Okay, I think we start to
get a bit friendlier soon, which I think adds another angle to
this which I'll discuss. I did take some shots at you and did
talk about the cabal and I won't deny that. I think you've defeat
first and overcommitted a position mind you. I may have even
I may have even agreed with you on
so he's even saying here he might have agreed with me but because
I said in relation to him the big street might be on. It's bridge
burn time. You dude bro I never said I wasn't taking shots at
Nick. I made some comments talking about the big street might
be on and Nicholas ended up covering it. Whether or not he was
going to definitively is up for debate, of course. Okay.
You can't open up with a great >> I should say this for
uh Aiden apparently asks why why do I think he's doing everything
Nick tells him to do. I think it basically breaks down to you
propagating a rumor that favors Nick entirely with no upside
for anything else that like Nick would want propagated and you
have no evidence for it. You say it's from a call. Apparently
you didn't record the call. You can't show any evidence at all.
So >> on day one, you're supposed to see if they sweep
first. Hence,
the great sweep might be on. The big sweep might be on, but nonetheless,
we're repeating ourselves. Okay. >> Yes. Hence why I said
look at who covers this and who doesn't. So Nicholas thinks because
I said it's about him, it's only about him. Look at who covers
this and who doesn't applies to multiple people. Who covers it
and who doesn't. And again, he's trying to make it about
Who was that specifically a jab at? Everyone or me? Okay.
Right. So, because I've said to him it was about him, he wants
to make it. It's all about him. When it's who does and doesn't
talk about this. It's so obvious, bro. It's so obvious. It's
so obvious, dude.
Everything I ever say is about you and you alone. Dude,
it does feel a bit virtuously to the chat to be sucking yourself
off over and over again about how brave you are for covering
someone to ignore it. I don't feel like I was doing that, but
so be it. If in a week you were ranting about it, I'd understand,
but we all know how this works and it takes people a few days
to >> Okay, hold on. covering something graveyard for covering
something when people haven't even had a chance yet to ignore
it. Um, no, I think that's probably correct. Ch >> even
happening because they're or just now getting to it. But again,
I'll save the rest of my takes um on this for when we talk on
stream. So, was that not intended to be about to be about jab
at me just for clarification?
Yes. I mean, based on the fact you swer topics, I was somewhat
thinking of you, but you were covering it, so I guess >> like
he jumped the gun, but he also spoke conditionally. It's not
like he said these people are sweeping. He was saying I expect
you to sweep. Right. So I guess if Nick's primary concern is
Chud's audience, calling him a sweeper. If that's the thing,
if Nick was just projecting the fear onto Chud that he actually
has, then I understand Nick's criticism. If Nick is just saying
you called the sweepers, he didn't. He said, "I expect you to
sweep." Which is different. And you proved him wrong. And that's
like the start and end of the issue. You go, "Huh, I did cover
it. You
you. Dude, I had a discussion with somebody last night about
how the fs slur just is so much better than I would like I would
like to get it removed from like 2s on a bunch of platforms.
It's like so it's so much more satisfying to use.
It's so much more satisfying to use. It's not close, man. >> It's
not. And this is the thing, dude. This is the thing. the reason
and I find myself catching I have to catch myself recently because
I start to go to use it because I've been using it in private
people who aren't gay in private and I'm like I can't use it.
It like hits well but Nick felt so called out by the comment
is because he wasn't sure whether he was going to talk about
it. So what I'm saying here well you are talking about it so
it doesn't apply to you does it but it did apply to him and then
he decided to cover it so it doesn't apply to him and he wants
to act upset that I even dare suggest it might be on. It's so
obvious, dude. I was I was just looking for yes or no. Not really
interested in the backstory.
Also, all Garcy you I'm not sucking myself off of how brave I
am. Dude, it feels like I am insane. If this was aan 20 videos
by now, I'm like, bro, am I crazy here? It's just true. Even
if the allegations are total Even if the allegations are total,
okay,
it's just true that there'd be 20 videos about some, but that's
not what Turkey Tom and that's yeah, he's a well-connected guy
and he's friends with some of these people and there's VidCon
parties and stuff like that, but no one seems to really want
to gr grasp that. It's just, oh no, more Pegasus covers this
or no, it's all about Nicholas.
You know, this is true. It's easy money, but because he's it's
a commentary golden boy radio silence from all these
Yeah. See, Assan is easy money, but covering Tom is more difficult.
Hence why the only larger channel will do it. Bro, off. I'm not
saying I'm a large channel. So, commentary broadly is just totally
compromised in dude. You're the only one who will brave the wilderness
and expose Tomstein. Unraped Unk over here will light the way.
I love Ougie. I
Okay, hold on. I'll I'll do this. Okay,
10 subs. I'll pull Aiden to the channel right now.
Uh I I'll probably pull him in anyway. I'll talk to him. I don't
know if it's going to be tonight, but people seem to be really
upset about this. I don't think there's anything wrong. If people
are that mad, if they think I'm like that outside my like if
I'm that outside the norm here, I like I'm fine with it, but
I don't think I am. I don't think I said anything crazy about
the guy. >> I do love feel bad about him getting involved.
I did say I wasn't going to involve him. I guess it turned out
to be a tough >> in the waiting room. >> There's
another thing.
There's another thing, guys. Another another ch logic lie. Okay.
And
I'm just glad we have something else to talk about. Not sure
if England's
>> What is that? Black ice with 10. Okay. Yeah, we can
do it. I honestly I think I was going to do it anyway, but I
just I wanted to I wanted to blackmail. If he joins the waiting
room, I could pull him
I just wanted to
I just wanted to see if I get the money
in in for Nicholas to suck out. Okay, that is legit banter. Come
on now. So, I explain it and it goes down better. It actually
goes down a bit better. True. A good old school scandal makes
me nostalgic thinking about the old days. And Nicholas actually
responds in a kind of He does get it. It turns out he does get
it.
You said he's spreading a rumor for Nick. Uh, I think he's spreading
a rumor that only favors Nicholas
without evidence. And I said if he has evidence, I said this
earlier, he has evidence for
He has evidence for it. I would just apologize and say, "Oh,
that's my bad." But I I don't know what evidence there could
be. Anyway, >> there are a few left. If you cover one or
two more, you could probably get the house. So, wow. Would you
look at that? Nicholas is responding in kind to banter. I made
it clear it's banter and he's responding in a favorable way.
I like I I say what I feel and I say why I feel that way. You
don't like that. That's fine.
But that's what it is, man. >> Hey, we got there. Yeah,
we got there in the end. But what's >> how does it favor
how does it favor Nicholas to spread a rumor that they're going
to like legally try to get the site taken down that's getting
run for the Discord? Well, the site gets taken down with no intervention.
How does that >> interesting about this and the thing I
want to point out >> and Nicholas, by the way, Nicholas
said that's a total lie, right? Oh, yeah. Sure, sure, sure, sure.
I'm telling you why I said it. And if he showed that like he
doesn't want to hang out with Dick or whatever, I I I didn't
feel like it was that consequential.
It's sort of like the big sweep thing. I I just said it because
I'm like, this seems really weird to me that you say this thing
that gets stuff done. It's totally Nicholas's favor. I might
have been hyperbolic about it, but if you want to talk about
it, I'm totally fine, >> And the reason that I feel so
blindsided by this holiday attack is look how kind of like amicably
this ends. It's honestly wild. >> Doesn't that look bad
when you spread the rumor with no evidence of that rumor at all?
Listen, I like Dioro rodeo. I don't like that it got taken down.
If Nicholas was never doing anything about
right? Then I'm like I'm sitting here and I'm like, dude, that's
that's I like that site. >> And this is why this was such
a blind side because we'd spoken about this
twice.
Once in >> Oh, that would also be interesting. I guess
the idea that he's working together with Dan Saltman would also
be interesting to me if we had any evidence of that. That would
also be interesting. Twitter DMs and then another time in this
tea party chat and it ended like on a sort of amicable basis.
So yes, it was kind of surprising when when Tom's response came
out, Nicholas did this big attack on me and >> is Aiden
is Aiden not joining? I got subs to get him to join. Totally
good to talk if he wants to talk. >> Continue onwards as
I've responded to him because I thought like okay we've had disagreements
but that's kind of it really. But he's reiterated them as part
of the Tom response to make me look terrible.
Continuing on. Honestly, see, look, I respond in kind because
I like having a bit of banter. I like having a little bit of
banter. So, I'll give a bit of banter back. Honestly, just glad
you never did a collab with go the microphone. That would be
fuel for me personally.
For sake, man. Look at how the cabal works. I'm getting ready
to be brought back in line, dude. Oh, that's also gay. That's
also gay. That's also gay. There's only one fsler you to come
back in line.
Like I guess maybe Zyl is kind of doing something. Augie is pretty
clearly just stating facts. Augie's not saying you can't have
a criticism. Augie is saying here's my criticisms of your your
criticism.
So I think this is this is a a Nicholas Yoryo coded message.
So I'm trying to have a little bit of a jovial thing like you
know because I do you know I do like Oie. I have been friends
with Nick in the past. Obviously things are a bit tense but I'm
trying to have a bit of a laugh and cool things down a bit. We've
had a little argument and just have a bit of a laugh now. Okay.
to a bit of banter.
And then what's this? Nick says, "Wow, it looks like Nicholas
is being friendly back. Would you believe it?
I appreciate you guys taking Aiden
right before he imploded. That saved me another round of this
lull." Oh no. Dude,
I'm sorry. >> Is he waiting? Pull him in. >> I'm
sorry. Like a Palestinian child.
Yo, so um I just wanted to ask you what claim do you think I
made that was favorable to neck?
>> Uh that that he was going to take legal action against
the Dioro.io thing.
>> Okay. First of all, the uh the claim that you specifically
uh quoted or said that in regards to Nick citing that I said
there was going to be a lawsuit, which I didn't that was Lumpy
Willy's like reiteration of my statement, but to be fair, Nick
was the one that actually ran with that. My statement uh was
that he was going to take some sort of action. My assumption
would be a DMCA, which is why I tipped Rita off, right? I don't
know how him getting I don't know how him with in this community
throwing a fit over like his server being archived and like threatening
to DMCA as a result of it makes him look favorable. >> You
just said legal action.
>> You didn't say DMCA. >> You said legal action.
>> What I Okay. No, but what I just said to you was that
I was thinking like a DMCA. That's what I just said.
>> That's the legal action, not a lawsuit. I was thinking
like a DMCA.
>> Okay. That would like expose the identity of the person.
Probably get them to take the thing down.
>> So, I was just like, "Oh, what what evidence do you
have of this?" was was my thinking. And then I was like, it just
seems
a bunch of things that line up with what he wants. >> My
your specific statement was that it makes him look favorable.
How does that make him look favorable?
>> Uh, it helps him. It favors him. It helps him. I don't
think it makes him look favorable. If I said makes him look favorable,
I didn't mean that. I would have just said it helps him. >> I'm
pretty sure you said that. Yeah, said that multiple times. Okay,
so we're going to get we're going to concede on that one. Okay,
so it's now that it helps him, right? >> I mean, it's not
what I meant. If I said it makes him look good, I don't know
why I would say be throwing a It makes him look good. It helps
him. He doesn't want the server up. It's favorable to >> Yeah.
Just just to be clear, you said it makes him look favorable.
I think you said that twice. Um but yeah, that would be the implication
of that, but I guess you that's fine. I guess you misspoke two
times. Um >> the No, that is what you said. >> You
think that helps you that I misspoke two times? You like say
it like it's a >> No, no. I'm just I'm No, no, no. I'm
just saying that was a >> Yeah, cuz it seemed like when
I had misspoke in the gamma argument, uh you're very quick to
interpret that as like a malicious lie, right? So it's now it's
gone from saying spoke twice, did you not? Did you misspeak on
both sides of it? No, no. What I said first was Gamma got Meera
into a VC. Then the second statement was that Meera joined a
VC in Gamma server. Not that the Gamma got implies that he was
the one that brought her in there, which wouldn't be true. And
that was the misspeak. Those two words, right? When presented
with a clip of me saying that, despite not thinking I said it,
cuz it wasn't what I was thinking, I immediately conceded and
said, "If I said that, that was not what I meant." Right. >> You
said go to the clip because I didn't
>> I didn't say that. I just said if I did, it's fine.
That's not what I meant. >> Because Yes. Yes, because I
didn't. Yes, because I didn't think I said that. And then being
presented proof that I did in fact say that, I immediately made
a con. >> were arguing against that without
>> Okay. No, I had argued again. Yeah. So, I'd argued against
I was being accused of stating something. I didn't believe I
had said it. So, I said I didn't say it and then you had shown
me uh you'd show me the proof that I said it and then I immediately
conceded it. So, back to this argument, right? Back to this argument.
Yeah, you staked out a position against gamma and gamma told
you you were lying and so we had to go back to check the evidence
because you both were arguing. >> Yeah, you had also interpret
that as a lie. You had also asserted that was a lie. That wasn't
just gamma >> because you're willing to double down on
it. You understand I didn't double down, right? I just said,
"Okay, if I said that it's not what I meant." >> Could
you think perhaps me asserting >> claim happening, right?
>> Yeah. So, you had said twice, you had said two times
that I was saying something that makes him look favorable,
>> Yeah. it helps him.
>> Okay. So, yeah. So, saying it makes him or it makes
him look favorable and saying it helps him. Those are not the
same thing. >> Um, now in regards to it helps >> when
you came and said this, I immediately clarified, >> right?
Yeah. Cool. Oh, I might have misspoken. It's not a concession.
You said that's not what I said. Sorry, that's not what I meant.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You misspoke. Yeah, you misspoke twice.
It's fine. Um, I'm >> I didn't say you're lying. I didn't
do that. I would never do that. Which is what you did in the
gamma thing, >> just to be clear. I I'm I'm just saying
right like with the gamma thing that was an obvious misspeak,
right? I just explained how and the doubling down on it, right?
It would probably be more likely that I didn't believe that I
had said that if I was saying I didn't say it on a stream where
you could easily rewind and verify that that claim was incorrect.
That would be an incredibly risky lie that would serve absolutely
like no benefit to myself because it would take 2 seconds as
it did to prove that I did in fact say that which I immediately
gave a concession on. That was obviously a misspeak, which is
why I immediately conceded. So I'm saying here when you asserted
a claim twice that I what I that I was saying things that make
him look favorable, I'm accepting
different things, but it's fine. You can go forward. >> No.
Yeah, they are they are different things, right? We compare things
that are different, right? The the parallel >> we just
watched a not so debate. So I just when I see like the weird
signaling instead of just having the conversation, I just point
it out as weird. >> Yeah. I don't I don't know about your
not Sora diet. It's like your Destiny mind. I'm not really interested
in this side of the community, so I don't particularly care.
What I care about is another version of that. >> How do
you think I ated him? >> How do you think I ated him? >> You
got the server taken down.
>> Okay. So, I actually told Rita to not take the server
down cuz I would be found out. I said, "Do with this information
what you will." When Rita was going to delete the website, I
said, "Don't do that.
He'll know it was me." Right? To be fair to you, you could say
to be fair to you, that meant like in the moment, don't take
it down. >> We have proof. >> Like I literally just
said
>> Yeah, I showed the DMs literally days ago, but I could
do it again for you cuz you just like to reiterate claims without
actually uh looking at anybody's >> I literally I actually
do. Are you aware that I literally said if you just showed me
like proof that this wasn't the case? I would just say, "Oh,
my bad." >> Yeah, I showed the proof publicly days ago,
but I can do it again. No worries. Um, hold on. So, >> he's
trying to do the slower mark under the breath thing, but couldn't
even get the zinger out. Yeah, he does that a >> This is
the comparison to Not Soite. Um, Notite and Destiny don't hang
out anymore, by the way. So, it's not really comparable. It's
not like the same >> Wow,
that's super cool, bro. Okay, here's the uh screenshot. >> The
screenshot. Okay,
what is this? Uh, I might take Not now. He'll know I said some
[__] Okay.
>> Yeah. So, there's your proof.
>> What was the Dioro DMs?
>> What Dioro DMs >> of him talking about working
with Dan on something and then of him >> So, so Oh, okay.
Got it. So, you didn't even actually like look at the original
source of the claim because I clearly said that occurred over
call. I'm curious where did you hear about this >> I just
looked at the logs I saw which was you saying all I saw >> when
did I see that happen in messages? Yeah. and those logs. I never
said this happened in messages. >> So, I just figured if
you make claims that like favor other people
>> or you with no evidence, then I am suspicious of why
you're doing that. >> Okay. But that doesn't favor him.
That's the That's the point. That makes him look like a sensitive
>> No, it favors him by by literally getting the thing
taken down that he doesn't want. >> Wait, why would a DMCA
not do that?
>> Um, wait, but he could do it without a DMCA. He could
do it without any effort. Yeah. Yeah. So, if he's going to get
it taken down via DMCA, why would my role be necessary here?
>> So, there's some [__] like this. I just
got sent these DMs. Dory has coordinated with Dan Helman to do
something specific about something. He wasn't specific. They
have an op on this server. Additionally, he suggested taking
legal action against Rita with Dan's help. So, you said this
and I'm wondering what evidence you have of this.
>> Yeah. So I, as I said at the time, I I literally said
prior to leaking this, I'm I can say it. I can leak it, but I'm
not going to have any proof substantiating this because this
occurred in a call, right?
>> I said this at the time. I said this >> Have you
not said to me multiple times that you record all calls?
>> Like literally, one time I asked you about some call
that you could have recorded. You're like, "Yeah, I usually record,
but I couldn't cuz I'm driving." Were you driving for this? >> I
don't JTock. I don't have a license. How could I drive? I've
never dri I' literally drove a car >> maybe traveling.
>> Why would I be able to drive in? I don't have a license
reach. Why aren't I able to drive in another country? I can't
>> I'm recalling a previous conversation. Do you not normally
have private calls that drive? Dude, the only time I've ever
driven the only time I've ever driven my mom was in the passenger
seat. I went in like circles parking lot. >> Uh, so what
I'm remembering is a Cameron F305 situation where you got a call
with somebody. You said clearly your memory is dog because you
literally use me driving as a example. I can't even >> Did
this not happen? >> You're trying to You're trying to do
your weird thing where you just bear down on like one thing I
said when I immediately go, "Oh, actually >> that's not
one thing that literally calls your entire memory into question."
That's a pretty big detail, don't you >> It doesn't. No,
it's not actually. It's not. You just substantial at all. That's
a pretty big detail to get wrong because you just >> your
frame of reference for your frame of reference for remembering
the important part.
>> You said something about driving. I don't even drive.
>> Uh I'm about to drop a slur on you. So just give me
a second.
>> You're being right now. Okay. So I need you to chill
for two seconds and understand that the substantial thing happening
here. >> I'm upset you're getting upset you're getting
caught in your lies. You're upset you're getting caught in your
lies. It's okay. >> No, you're being a fler right now.
And I >> No, you're lying and you're being caught on it.
And I know that sucks. >> The substantial thing here is
when you said that you usually record stuff, but you didn't in
this case because of some >> I never said that. Just like
I never said I would have been a liar. You're literally a liar.
>> We were all bothering you to to play this recording
of some call. You wouldn't play it for us. And then somebody
asked about something else. You're like, I usually do record
stuff. I didn't in this case because of some reason. I can't
remember the reason. I thought it was that you were driving,
but I don't remember the reason. Well,
I don't know why you would think that. And I don't know why you
would think I I said that cuz I don't record calls. It's actually
illegal in my state. The I actually that's not true. I've recorded
I have broken the law and recorded the Boax call. I think that's
the last one I've recorded. >> That was like a year ago.
But yeah, in my state totally you take like calls about content
privately and don't record >> Okay. That's your advice,
right? But you're making a a literally foundational fundamental
advice for like every single person on the entire internet. So
people don't like calls like that. >> That's great. I I
I didn't really asked for advice uh from the guy that like >> Do
you disagree with that? Do you disagree with that? >> Dedicated
dedicated his career to trying to compensate for being a collaborator
criminal whose girlfriend whose girlfriend is in >> You
don't disagree with that at all. >> To get her stuff out
of your mouth.
>> No, I I don't think I I don't need to record now. has
to go to other unrelated issues because he can't deal with the
substance again. >> No, you're you're No, you're literally
pivoting to boring to talk to. This is literally why I didn't
want to talk to you to be honest. If you were an interesting
doctor like I would probably talk to you, but you're a boring
care about the doc totally boring.
>> You're like totally boring. Hey JTO, >> you're
not entertaining. You're not interesting. You're [__]
boring.
focus on little minor issues that aren't substantive at all.
You think you can win debates on them? It's so boring. It's why
nobody wants to talk to you.
>> Really? That's >> I didn't want to talk to you.
I'll just go back to covering the logic stuff. It's so boring.
>> I mean, divine intervention. Really? I'll give him a
little bit.
>> Okay. Okay. Good times. Great times. Great. Great. Great
times.
Okay. Are we back to the Chud stuff now?
He wasn't driving. I'm literally like trying to remember something
from like a year and a half ago. Random
He was like, "Oh, I didn't record this cuz something was happening."
I thought he said he was driving, but I can't remember. Maybe
he's traveling. Maybe he was like in a different state. I can't
I'll see at some point. How can you drive without a license?
Yeah, I don't I don't I'm not like married to the claim he's
driving. It's not a part of the
It's It's literally not substantive.
I ended my Twitch for that.
It's too bad.
Okay. All right. We're good. We're good to move forward and chill
and do whatever. You were implying a lot about him. Um, yeah.
I was probably too hyperbolic. Yeah, I was probably too hyperbolic
if I said he'd do anything Nicholas wanted, but my core thing
was, "Oh, this seems like weird that you'd say this then not
have evidence of it at
Um, maybe this helps him a little bit. Yeah. What else do we
have to talk about? But it seemed like we were at the end of
the conversation. No. Did we have something else to talk about
that was
I called him an f slur.
I said he was doxing. Well, actually, technically, then he brought
up my relationship. Then I said he was doxing.
It's like realistically if he just wants to talk about that stuff,
he could do that on his own stream.
Was there something substantive to talk about still?
I understand you guys just want me to with him. I don't really
care to.
It's so It's like super boring. I
I just don't If there's something substant I'll ask him if there's
something substantial. Hello. >> Oh, wait. He did. >> You
have something substantial to bring back here? Are we I think
we're done, right? We're at the end. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Well, no. I just wanted to ask you a quick question if that's
okay with you. Um the doxing point, right? I just was wondering
what substantially changed between you uh figuring out I doxed
talking about it on stream and then obliging and joining the
chat where this docs was reposted
uh on the forget what day it was days after you had acknowledged
and talked about the fact that I >> genuinely felt bad
for you that your life was like falling apart and you were like
totally rattled and losing your >> So, okay. So, I'm asking
what's changed?
>> What's changed? Well, that's not me collaborating with
you. That's me being in a Discord. >> Okay. I was back
on your stream again. Uh you hosted the whole like gamma conversation
about Goat Kat, which was way more light-hearted. Um so I'd say
that was collaborating, right?
>> Yeah. I I again um was being kind, didn't want to immediately
point out that I didn't want to collab with a doxer when brought
it up and then you joined before I had a chance to respond tangibly,
I think. >> Okay. And then you you and then you so despite
taking issue that you never like removed me or anything or or
brought it up or it was just like this is a point that has only
come up conveniently after that stream ended uh with me making
a joke about your uh your ex
which I suspect is the real reason for >> Yeah. So I'm
I'm just like I think the timeline doesn't really make sense
because nothing's changed
except the joke about Cherry.
>> I literally just said I didn't really want to collab
with you.
>> yeah, but after >> I guess if if you think I refuse
to collab with you because of the Cherry joke, then I don't understand
why I'd collab with Chud. >> I I haven't seen Chud's joke
about Cherry. Uh, I don't know. Maybe because there's more benefits
to Chud. You want to look past some of the uh some of the uh
he's a bigger creator. You want to look past some of the shortcomings?
I don't know. Um, but that's the only thing that's substantively
changed. uh and you're between the time you realized that I had
spread a docs and I see uh versus now and in between that time
you were interacting cordially. You even join the text chat where
this happened. So I guess I just explain to you why I joined
the text chat
>> cuz out of because you felt it was a sympa it was a
sympathy draw.
>> I just felt bad that like all of your was falling apart.
Yeah. that you were like melting down because of this girl or
whatever and like all of your was was going and I was like, "Oh,
it feels bad. I'll join and be there in solidarity." >> Okay.
Um it's just like weird since like supposedly like the entire
notion
of associating with me uh irks you right now despite an event
that you already knew about at that point in time. But I guess
I don't know, maybe you've just come to a sudden epiphany. It's
just crazy coincidence. Do you do you really actually like you're
saying it with a >> Is that all? >> You're totally
saying it with tone and it that tone
in this conversation at all. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes. I don't know if you're need direct communication. The
implication is I don't believe you. Um I just think that's like
super convenient. Um and it just doesn't align with like I don't
know why you'd be willing why you'd be willing to if you think
it's like a bad idea to be associating with a docer. why any
like bits of sympathy would like completely overlook that temporarily
and you'd be able to act cordially with me from multiple interactions
after that point supposedly to issue me calling in. >> that's
your problem is I'm no longer acting cordially with you.
>> Yeah, that could have something to do with the comment.
Maybe. >> that I like felt bad for you and then you made
me not feel bad for you anymore and so I stopped acting cordially.
But nothing else changed.
>> Yeah. The thing that made you not feel bad was that
cherry joke, right?
Uh, was you not acting cordially? >> Yeah. So, I made a
joke. I'm pretty sure you took multiple digs at me over the goat
[__] while I was on that stream.
>> I'm pretty sure I was just reciprocating. Was I not?
>> Wait, were you reciprocating?
>> What was the dig I took? What was the dig I took? >> Um,
I'm pretty sure you made several jokes about I don't remember
the specific jokes by name or by exact terminology. We can go
uh I can go >> So, so the thing Why did you bring the cherry
thing up then? Could it be because I made gokado jokes? So what's
the criticism?
>> Oh yeah, I'm just making a joke about >> So what's
>> Well, the the criticism wouldn't >> So there's
What's the criticism? Yeah.
>> Yeah. So the criticism here is like I think you're like
a crybully, right? Cuz like if it's totally fine like talking
about my pursuits and I think it is fine, right? It's it's publicized.
It's out there. You have every right to make fun of that. But
>> it's literally what the content was
>> but if the difference between >> literally in
the scope of the content >> was was my relationship the
scope of the content. By the way, I'm not even saying that's
what it was. I'm just I don't even have to go into litigating
any of that because nobody's going to believe me if I say that's
not what it was. I'm just proving to your audience that you're
a disingenuous loser
that you disingenuous comments about goat and that's why you
took something you brought something in from outside to try to
go after me.
>> Wait, no. I matched your [__] energy. You
were making fun of my pursuits. Why couldn't I not make fun of
yours? >> Joke about something that was in the scope of
the content and then you went outside the scope of the content
to try to get back at me.
Yeah. I I honestly I don't like I don't know how
like I brought it in now. That's part of the scope of the content
cuz I brought it in with my joke. >> Huh. I was just re
like the scope the scope of the content was making fun of me
for my pursuit. >> The scope of the content was a debate
with you and uh with you and Gamma that all kicked off because
of the co goat drama. So I was giving the leadup to that whole
drama explaining what
>> at which you had made jokes about at my expense and
I merely matched the energy. So I don't know why you couldn't
just like like I don't know why that would be why you wouldn't
just see that as like reciprocation and laugh it off. I don't
understand why that would be the difference between
me or not. nice to you because I felt bad that your [__]
was getting blown up. And then
and then after that I was like, "Oh, I guess like the cordiality
whatever. >> I shouldn't be associating."
>> Okay, so you felt Okay, got it. So you felt bad, but
you were still want to make those jokes of my like at my expense,
which by the way I would have taken away your perms no matter
what at the end of that conversation because I don't want you
to be able to join my
>> Yeah, that's fine. I just don't Yeah, that's fine. I
just think you're super dishonest. Regardless of your comments,
regardless of anything, I was going to take away your perms as
soon as I realized you had perms.
>> Yeah. And just to be clear, uh, did you not like collaborate
with someone for years who was actively doxing people?
>> You talk about Dan.
>> Uh, yeah. I had a problem with that. I obviously said
if you ever try to do something like that, that's the name, by
the way. Not talk about location, not talk about profession,
not talk about that stuff. Right. >> All right. You yourself
conceded. You yourself conceded that the workplace, the occupation
I made up that she allegedly previously worked at, you admitted
that I could have conceivably made that up and got that right.
You conceded to that yourself on that >> I understand how
that could happen.
>> you're still talking about a bunch of things, but you
understand that that's still bad, right? I I didn't concede that
that was like good. >> Of course, >> I could see
that it's believable. I could see that if you're going to talk
about that, you are you are doxing that
>> Okay. Yeah, I spread that. I can understand how it happens.
>> The you've still done it.
>> Yes, but what you're Okay, but you're trying to minimize
you're trying to minimize Dan, right, T? Like, what I did actually
cross the line that would be additionally worse than Dan? There
are several factors that existed in my case that wouldn't be
existent in Dan's case. Isn't this repeat behavior? Is hasn't
is hasn't this been like hasn't this occurred over a substantial
period of time with me? I got drunk one night. I put in two keywords.
It was the first YouTube channel um because they've already been
giga doxed over and over again because he gives out all their
he gives out like uh their address and I repost it in my server
to be a edge lord while I was drunk and it was it was bad.
There is no excuse for that. But I think
a log were you literally a log Leo Comboy's content, right? >> Where
you have all of the Leo Comboy
>> No, none of the Leo Convoy haters were in that chat.
That was a separate segregated chat because everyone in the server
hates the ACC people.
>> Yeah. So, I'm just trying to explain like why it would
actually probably there would be
I'm pretty sure worse judgments about Dan's character than there
would be in my case. I don't remember exactly what Dan had done
at that point.
I obviously had major problems with these people and yeah, I
was trying to extricate myself from that ever happening again.
I was trying to make sure that never happened again.
Obviously, it was like a what do you call it? Like a sign of
things to come with these people. >> Okay. But they had
not gone anywhere near where they'd already gone and so I don't
have a high tolerance for it
>> I appreciate that. But do you believe there's redemption
for yourself, right? >> Uh, sure.
>> Sure. So, I'm I'm trying to figure out exactly like
um I'm trying to figure out exactly like why uh like this stain
uh causes permanent disassoci like you think probably you would
never want to associate as a result of that. I don't want to
associate with you. So, that's not really like what I'm asking.
I'm trying to gauge your standards here. That's not true. You
literally asked me to join your Discord after this happened,
so you're just lying there. >> Well, yeah. No, no, that's
not a lie. You are now, okay, you've admitted that something
has changed. So, you can't use the example where you prior to
the change where you supposedly felt bad for me as like as evidence
of the active
me now that this has happened.
>> No, no, that's not what I just said. You just did a
really like dishonest thing. You yourself claimed that the standing
the standing of the association when you joined my text chat
is not the standing of the association today because at the time
you felt bad for me. Right? So if we're talking about the standing
of the association as it exists right now, I don't know why you're
citing that as your supporting or as your supporting example
for where the association >> fine with associating. You
were fine with joining my stream, right?
>> You were fine with joining my stream. I'm not the one
that
I'm literally saying you're like I don't want to I don't want
to associate with you. You're implying that like you have no
interest. You have no interest based. You're basically saying
like you you're ugly anyway after I've rejected you. You understand
that's what you're doing, right? You're replaying the goat. No.
>> What? No. Okay. Just so we're just so we're clear. I
have no problem associating you. I'm saying now like I don't
like to assoc people who are dishonest. Right. At the time I
didn't think you were dishonest. Now I do. >> Yes. Sure.
Yes. You've engaged in like a you've engaged in a pattern of
dishonesty that I've called that on this stream tonight. Yes.
So, I've come to the realization you're dishonest and don't want
to associate her as a result. >> Okay. I think that you've
completely made up like some to explain why despite knowing about
the docs over an extended period of time, all your attitude is
completely cordial and file. And then after I make a joke about
like your psycho ex that everyone warns you about, all of a sudden
that attitude changes and it's like I don't want to associate
with a doctor even though you're fine with that association to
begin with, right? And you engaged in numerous cordial interactions
since learning about that. I literally hang out with a whole
bunch of other people who make the same jokes. Like that stuff
that's public. I don't like totally disavow people who make those
jokes.
>> Yeah. So the the decision to hang out with people is
multifaceted. That could bother you, but these people could be
beneficial to you in other ways, right? Chud Logic is way more
influential than myself. You probably have a crossover audience.
Like he there's benefits to Chud, right? That where you'd be
willing to look past any like bother that you would have over
him making jokes, right?
So, I don't know what that point was. >> Lots of other
people have made the jokes. Lots of other people made the >> Yeah.
I'm I'm explaining how those people
have. >> Is everybody Is everybody else more valuable than
you
>> in the context of your relations? Yes. I'm not I've
never been particularly close with you or beneficial to you.
So, yeah, obviously. No.
>> All right. Well, yeah. So, I just I just Right. Perry's
made a whole bunch of jokes about that stuff and he's way smaller
than you.
I'm not close to him. In fact, I've actually fought with Perry
way more than you. I literally I've literally like hated Perry
in the past. We used to fight all the time.
Anytime I was in a spicy VC, Perry would come in and try to talk
[__] to me. >> Oh, Perry actually disproves
this >> Uh, does he is he active making cherry jokes or
was he making cherry jokes at the time when >> Yeah, he
makes tons of cherry jokes. GO WATCH HIS STUPID ACC not ACC commentary
awards for 2025.
Making jokes all the time. Does he do it on your stream when
he calls in?
>> He's never not done it. He called in just to ask me
if I was like making sure my relationship would work. He's like
pressed me about my relationship on my stream. Yes. >> Okay,
fair enough then. I guess I guess Perry I guess Yeah, Perry Perry
disproves that. Uh the joke would be the reasoning. I guess I'm
trying to
>> But yeah, I just I >> Okay, hold on. Hold on.
I don't disassociate with Perry. Perry is currently banned for
leaking a streamable a non-sreamable channel, but it's actually
like a procedural issue. Okay.
Not the same thing. >> Oh, so okay. So, okay. So, just
like you disassociated with me for a reason other than the joke.
Perry's banned for a reason other than the jokes,
just to be >> Yeah, but Perry, like literally I watch Perry's
stuff still. Like, I like Perry. I like the content. He got banned
for a procedural thing. He uh he leaked a voice chat with somebody.
He wasn't supposed to do it and it's in the rules. He got taken
down on a procedural issue. But again, Perry's really funny.
>> I might let Perry get away with something crazy. Okay.
If Perry wants to talk about Leo Convoy's wife and where she
works, I it's possible he gets away with it. Okay,
>> that guy, he's just funny. He can just do it. Okay,
he can just get away with
>> So, okay. So, just I guess to finish off, do you can
see it on the clamp that I uh that uh my narrative was favorable
to Dior? Because that's what I called in here about. >> No,
I still think I still think it's totally favorable to Dioro and
you.
>> Okay. Well, then I don't think your mind's going to
be changed. I don't think you want it changed. Um, this is obviously
not favorable to Dioro. Uh, the uh the entire reason, the entire
thing that I was leaking was his attempt to get the website taken
down, right? And I specifically advise when I leak this not to
take the website down. So, if the end goal that would be beneficial
to Dioro is the removal of the website, I'm actively seen discouraging
that as I presented evidence of. >> Wait, you're not seen
discouraging, you're discouraging it right now. >> Yes.
And I never encourage it. I never encourage them to take it.
I literally when I DM, I don't say take it down. I literally
say, "Uh, do that info what you will because this is a friend
of mine and I don't feel like I I don't feel right hearing about
possible intent to DMCA, a friend of mine without informing them."
When they suggest the idea of taking it down, the only time happens
I tell them not to do it.
>> What What about that line about him working with Dan
Saltman? Did he tell you he's working with Dan Saltman on
>> Uh, yeah. Dan's name came up in regards to the uh in
regards to Kosher Cathy's >> So, he's working with Dan
on something to do with Kosher Cathy.
>> Uh something like that. I don't remember. I don't know
the specifics of his involvement with Dan. I just know Dan's
name came up and I'm pretty sure my inference from the details
that were given to me is that Dan had an alt implanted in the
server and was scraping
>> Which doesn't look favorable to Dior because Dan is
like detested in this entire space. Um
I said or you are you having a fight with somebody like specifically
the owner of that server? Were you recently having a fight with
>> Yeah, but that was after this came out.
>> And also that would I don't know how that would aid
my fight against them that Dan was scraping the server. You're
just with them.
>> Okay. Well, I guess I It'd be weird because I'd be with
them before the beef. So, >> Simman just tipped $15.
Kick Aiden. >> Yeah. I don't know. Doesn't really make
a whole lot of sense, does it? >> Uh, maybe. I I know you
and Kathy have had beef in the past, but >> wait, what
VidCon thing?
What is there to bring? Did you talk about my VidCon leaks? That
didn't make Dior look favorable.
>> No, I didn't. I in fact if I referenced them it would
have been saying like to Beckett maybe that that you said this.
>> I I Okay, I guess
um >> I didn't even that [__] yet.
>> Yeah. All my leaks revealed like in in total about Dioro
was that he's like sensitive to the archiving of um he's sensitive
to the uh to the archiving of the server. He's considering DMCAing
somebody over it, right? He's working with somebody that potentially
that is universally uh detested in this community. And then the
VidCon leak also came out around the same time and that showed
that uh Chud was actually not delusional. Um and Diorio was wait
and Dioro was about him uh at the time uh while they were supposedly
still actively friends.
>> So yeah, none of this made makes him look good, but
uh you're not going to concede it, right?
>> I I think the I don't think any of it I already said
that I don't think it makes him look good. I said it helps. I
don't think the VidCon leaks help. >> Okay. Do you think
But you think the other leaks do?
>> The VidCon leaks work in your favor. They would change
my mind on this.
>> Okay. I'm glad. Uh
>> your mind has been changed.
>> Well, that up. >> Um Yeah. Take care. >> Have
a good one. Bye. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Uh thank you for the $15 sent man. I will probably
never take a donation from you to do anything. You're a total
loser. We're back to the Chud stuff. I think we're back to the
Chud stuff. >> The reason we're talking about this is cuz
he started leaking. The reason that I'm even bringing this up
now is cuz he started leaking. To be clear, he he posted the
messages, right? But I reached out to him and I wanted to have
a call about it to clarify what he said back in May and he ignored
me. So, if there is some weird angle to these messages that I
can't possibly deduce, he just chose not to talk about it.
>> By the way, when Aiden watches this and he sees that,
get ready for a 20-minute tangent because it was referenced once,
by the way. Okay.
H man, that was funny. Honestly, he [__] himself
over. Get >> you guys taking Aiden right before he imploded.
That saved me another round of this. Lol. >> So deep into
ACC drama. >> Well, I can agree there.
Wow. Look at >> I did I did I was losing like 50% KCIP
for that whole conversation.
God damn >> We're I would say this is a bit friendly. Wouldn't
you would you expect guys let me ask you this. Would you expect
Yes, we've had an argument. I'm going to talk to Ogie. Nick doesn't
want to talk. Whatever. But we've had a bit of a backwards and
fors about it, right? Would you expect off the back of this there
to still be unspoken resentment that it reveals itself when you
go on holiday? Like what? Things are like quite friendly at this
point.
But apparently I need to get wrecked when I go away.
>> Hello Gubby Bursters. Thank you very much for the gifted
sub. I appreciate it. I have not adjusted the timer. We've got
lots of time. Okay, we've got time to go through all of the stuff.
>> Well, we there >> and we even reference it here.
Ch's getting nervous. He's seeing visions of his chat watching
him engage in light banter with Fatty.
Yeah, man. I'm gonna get accused of sweeping for you f slurs
now. See, it's friendly. It's funny. It's jovial. It's jovial.
Why can't it just be like this? Maybe a bit more on stream content.
Okay. Anyway, that's your biggest nightmare. I do feel we're
talking past each other on some points, but it's all good. We
can hash it out when we talk next week or what you guys What
are you guys saying on the age play though? You think Tom is
wearing wearing or changing the diaper?
From what I know, diaper stuff is fake. Age play is unconfirmed,
but if he did it, that's a line way too far for me. Age play,
domestic violence, and recording without consent is my current
list from a non-starter perspective. That's my short list of
stuff he needs to address pending when I actually read the rest
of stream.
Be interesting to see what uh Nicholas's thoughts were on Tom's
response to the age play, which is about 3 minutes long. And
a message saying, "Uh, yeah, he didn't do that actually from
a person that maybe doesn't want to even admit there's an age."
Whatever. I digress. We don't need to get into that. Okay, dude.
I had a great bit about him being Epstein. Haha.
It does look rough now, but there is no way anyone took that
serious at the time. Gez, love, I feel bad for him being my friend
and all. If all this story ends up to an unproven allegation,
he got totally and these girls seem like pieces of to me regardless
of what he did, but that might be my sweep.
And then guys, once again, Chud
is too nice. Ch is fair. I don't know what you want to say about
this, bro. Off in my coverage. I said this. I was legit fair.
I wasn't doing the Kino Casino while I played everything up.
Yes, PPP. Yes, Andy Warski. You're a couple of jock jocks. constantly
boosting up to crazy levels. Okay, but listen, I'm running out
of allies as it is. So, we'll leave it there. Maybe it gets appearance
one day. I don't know. Who knows? Okay, >> they do. I You
have to look at Keto Casino's performance art. If you take Kino
Casino super seriously,
there's You got a problem. Okay, it's performance art. It's like
they're elevating things to a crazy level for fun. It's like
all satire, okay? It's not It's not like accurate reporting.
It's like artistry, okay? It's way different. People said I was
sweeping during my coverage. That's why I had to pass that on
to you guys to take the heat off me.
And then I say, also beyond the drama and talking and arguing,
I know what it's like to have embarrassing leak. It sucks. So
I do hope on a personal level he is doing okay.
So I even give a little bit of grace to say, "Hey, I know it
sucks and I hope he's doing okay."
which makes it all the more insane that these well this loser
is desperately trying to paint me as some sort of terrible horrible
snake person where I'm covering the allegations fairly and then
when I get an opportunity privately I say yeah it sucks it sucks
I get it and then I say oh sorry sorry
what am I doing here this one okay sorry I'm uh got to send messages
okay >> he needs to stop age regressed BPD
>> And uh you know it kind of it kind of >> This
is the second time I've seen these logs. I just want to see if
Chud has any broad like the takeaway I get from these logs is
that >> Chud's not being duplicitous. He's he's coming
with the same energy in both places. And that the idea that he
was like totally capitulating that he only was going after Dioro
like in these logs I also think is like just incorrect. Although
I think it's incorrect from sorry I think it's incorrect from
multiple perspectives. But obviously these logs back up the fact
that he's saying, "Yeah, I was taking a shot at you here." But
also, there's some other >> I would like to commend Ali
for not speaking during the discussion. I actually bit your amount.
Yeah, I know it's a bit awkward all around people start fighting.
I thought >> Does anyone take them seriously? Some people
do take them seriously. Yes,
some of them do. Some people do take them very seriously. >> Funny
to watch. Maybe soon we can bring the fighting onto stream and
actually make some content. So once again guys, if nothing else,
I hope you can at least start to understand why when this is
how it was left, we'd had a disagreement again, got to a sort
of amicable place, right?
Two weeks go by after this roughly. Okay, I go on holiday, Tom
drops the response and Nicholas goes on the attack against me.
Why not back then? Why not do it here?
Because Nicholas wanted to do it at a time when he thought I
wasn't going to respond instantly because he doesn't want the
smoke. And then I come back and I respond. They release a few
DMs. He releases a few more to try and make me look bad.
And I mean, look, make your mind up about this all you want.
I think this just shows what a pathetic, sensitive coward is
and how so much of what he said in that stream was projection.
Okay.
>> Oh, that's the big one. Yeah. Sorry. Sorry. That's the
big one. The big one is that when Nick says this guy's scared
of his audience,
it's pretty obviously him projecting that. that is not really
just a thing that he could throw a chud without obvious like
it's obvious what he's concerned about. In fact, he says as much
like in his own stream kind of like glosses over it. He might
even be trying to frame it as like yeah like of course I don't
like your audience. Look how scared you are of your audience.
But it's like Chud's not bringing this up that he's doing it
because of his audience. In fact, I think Nicholas also lies
in his own stream about some of those logs to paint it as Chud
being about his audience or Chud being scared of his audience,
which actually makes me think I need to go back and find the
line in here that I sent to Becket where I said Nick literally
reads one of these lines totally wrong to support his idea that
Chud is scared. Like Chud's clearly saying, "I'm frustrated,
so I'm crashing out." And Nick is like, "Well, Chud says he has
to crash out because his audience is pressuring him." Right?
He says that no reason to go after me. >> Hold on. Let
me uh pull up another time stamp here. I'm pulling up another
time stamp here. Let's see. We can find this. It's somewhere
in the Twitter DMs here.
>> Um yeah, I saw that. That wasn't you, bro. Dude, sometimes
you are very sensitive. I know it. >> You He's not happy
with what I got to say. Uh >> oh. Chud's doing tone indicators
for Nicholas. Not good.
Not good. Don't do the tone indicators. that nail any
>> what's wrong with that don't ask dropped I couldn't
make any forwards and talked about it at length of an audience
>> he will block people to the cows come >> it's
the second it's the second dash here this is the one where Nicholas
has to read this totally incorrectly to support his narrative
I wonder if going to call it out >> and he is going onto
this deranged tirade over me saying he might be
>> to ask what's the difference between crashing out and
talking [__] so my chat leaves me alone and the banter,
>> bro. Notice the little slight of hand he's done there.
It's so dishonest, bro. I say it leaves me feeling like I'm biting
my tongue. Sometimes have a crash out and talk some
fan the flames of wanting us to fight. I'm not saying I'm talking
to feed the
Okay, so he does see it. I don't know if he saw it or if he maybe
watched some coverage, but he does see it, which is good. This
is the thing I was trying to like basically pass on to Becket.
Now, I don't know. I think he backed it up, right? So, we're
going to hear it again, but listen to the way Nick reads this
to make it sound like Chud's saying, "Well, I have to crash out
so my audience doesn't cannibalize me so they don't go after
me." I'm saying that do I do that in spite of the fact that there's
this impact of the want us to fight and I'm not looking for a
big fight with a guy even at this point. Even at this point still
got some appreciation for the friendship, the things he's done
for me and I know that having a fight could upset that. We've
gone our separate ways already. He's come back wanting to talk
again. So I think well let's have another go. Thank you for the
$5.
The guy argued this takes the chat as audience caption not the
guy who just follows the main narrative and leads to the big
creators. Thank you for the $5. Thank you. >> I'm biting
my tongue. So, dude, I'm the >> I do feel I do feel bad
for Becket cuz I might have said that he brought this group chat
up and how Chad acted in it as like a thing and I he might not
have said that in our chat. I'm trying to think that might have
been somebody else who was saying that to me. So, now I I should
go lock that down as well cuz I I might have done Becket a disservice
on my stream last time. Yeah, I'll have to go see. >> You're
afraid of your chat. It leaves me feeling like I'm biting my
>> No, I'm biting my tongue because if I talk about you
too much, you get annoyed and you get upset, dude.
Uh oh. Uh Aiden moment. Well,
somebody, how do I put this? Somebody who Becket would have talked
to said this to me if not Becket himself. And Becket, I think,
was implicitly reaching for it. It's like the narrative that
was going around was that Chud did this that he mischaracterized
the group chat DMs. That was like the narrative that was going
around. So, while Beckett may not have said it himself and I
may have like thrown Becket under the bus there, it was being
said. >> How did he not get this? You're the problem, Nicholas.
You're the sensitive one. You can't hack it. >> Tug because
I have to crash out and talk some to fan the flames of wanting
us to fight. Now I have to ask what's the difference between
crashing out and talking [__] so my chat leaves me
alone and the banter.
>> I'm just curious when he >> Do you see how he
does that? Hold on. >> He says it's just bad. >> See,
that's the thing. He's framing it as I'm saying it to get my
chat to leave me alone. That's not what's happening. Right. Right.
Chat, >> you say more about how Queen was screaming at
Becket? No.
But I I hope one day
I It's No, I can't. I can't. Queen was very angry at at Becket.
But I think you could tell that from, you know, obviously we
were listening to the stream and you could tell how mad Queen
was while we were playing WoW, right? Right. The whole time we're
playing WoW and we're like listening to the Becket stream. You
could tell he was getting like increasingly upset about it over
time and like going off. And just imagine he like kept getting
mad and kept getting mad and then he eventually just blows the
[__] up. >> I want a confrontation. They want
a live stream confrontation, right? I wasn't delivering that.
Nicholas wasn't interested in having it. Okay. So, what we're
left with giving a couple of jabs every now and then, but it's
not that deep, right? I don't want to have a big blowout over
how he's covered Ethan Klein, but he's very sensitive. So, I
give these jabs and that still causes all this upset dude. And
it just feels like what can I do? I guess the only thing is to
just never talk about him. I can just never talk about Big Nick.
That seems to be the best solution to keep everyone happy except
me and also the, you know, people that are watching. But Nicholas
gets to Nicholas
gets to not be spoken about in a way that might upset him,
mate. And I do bad all the time, but in my messages, IT'S I'M
SCARED OF MY FANS. I'm scared of my fans.
I have to keep them at bay. I throw them a steak so they don't
eat me
Oh my god, dude. >> dude. Sean just dude, you know what?
You
he narrowed in so heavily
on this narrative
and I do feel like the group chat DMs and just broadly if you
just don't read this with the connotations without if you read
this without his like narrativizing of it.
If you do that and yeah, if you read it without his narrativizing
of it and you you listen to it without or I guess read the DMs
without his narrativizing, you can just see that that's not what
Chut is saying. Chut is not saying, "I'm scared of my audience,
so I have to throw them red meat sometimes." That would be that
would be crazy if he was saying that. Okay? Or if he was even
saying like, "Sometimes my audience gets really upset, so I have
to throw them red meat." He's saying, "I'm sweeping for you by
not mentioning this." And my audience when they call me sweepers
over this, or when they call me a sweeper over this, they're
being accurate. And that pissed me off. So sometimes I crash
the out about it.
That's obviously what's going on, >> bro. There are no
amount of stakes that can stop my chat from eating me alive,
bro. It's impossible. They're too They're too They're too ravenous.
They're too ravenous for my flesh, bro. I'm chucking sausages
behind me. They're still coming even faster. I'm thinking of
the Simpsons. Simpsons reference when chucks the Oh, he eats
the sausage, doesn't he? But you know what I mean. The idea is
give him the sausages and he gives him more strength to come
and get
My god's honest truth. Me to you. You should block them.
>> You should block every last one of them. >> How
do Dude, how do people like this? This is like what I'm I'm like,
how what am I insane here? This guy's a total
dude. This guy is such a
And he's sat there saying this. This is a John Wicker commentary.
Block people that say things you don't like, bro. It is so and
this is supposed to be some
>> you should block them. Like what are you on about, dude?
That's pathetic. That's >> pathetic. It's why people of
commentary is so cool a [__]
>> He's so cool, >> dude. Dude, some people get it.
Nick's either dishonest or so low IQ. He can't see the subtext
of your messages as you try you trying to be polite in saying
I disagree with you and want to say it on stream without you
seething. Exactly. Thank you for the $10. Thank you.
>> Should do it, Chad.
If Dude, Chad, just ignore. Dude, you know what you should do,
Chad?
My god's honest truth. Me to you. You should block them.
>> You should block every last one of them.
That's what I would do.
Oh, I have to fan the flames of who want us to fight. I get that's
bothersome for you. You message me BTS and we don't ever resolve
anything.
Dude, it is funny
it is funny how like if you if there is substantial criticism
of you and people become aware of it and they start repeating
it in large numbers and you just ban them instead of being able
to integrate them.
Right. Wait, JT, were you being sarcastic? I thought that was
clever.
Wait, what are you asking about? I'm I'm lost. Maybe I'm behind
here, Matt. I don't know what you're asking about. But if you
if you just ban everybody who disagrees with you and it's substantial
and it like makes a difference, you never ever like integrate
that criticism and acknowledge and and move forward with it,
you will build up a community of people who are that will fester.
That will absolutely fester. They'll find somebody who doesn't
like you. They'll go to that community. That whole criticism
will fester.
You do have to do something about it,
right? 100% you have to do something about it. If you do nothing,
that will fester. And that's what Nick fears now is he has created
a community of people who dislike him when he goes and bans all
these people who say like, "Hey, isn't it like a bit much with
Ethan stuff? Aren't you like maybe reading this a bit too terribly?
You really okay with Ethan just like DMCAing all these random
clips? That really okay?" And he just bans you instead of
That does create a community of people who are paying attention
to you, have been there for a long time, they know a lot of stuff
about you, and they can see how you're violating your own principles.
And then when they start gloming together like the oh what would
it be? It's like the H3 Stark people and the left it's like leftovers
H3 and there's like another one. It's not H3 Stark is it? The
people who were there after he broke up with his uh sister-in-law
for the podcast. I feel like when those groups start to glom
together, that's when you come into a real issue. They know everything
about you. They know every bad thing to say. They know everything
that upsets you. Frenemies H3. Yes, Frenemies H3.
You get stuff like that happening where you like start to put
these communities together
and if they like listen if there's especially when there's no
monetary incentive for them, right? Like the like the Reddit
like the Stark credits when there's no monetary incentive when
they're just doing it for the love of the game, there is no way
to get that back under control. It's up. Okay, dude. This dude
bro,
I'm not saying anything that crazy here, bro. It leaves me feeling
like a bite of my tongue. sometimes have a crash out and talk
some and do found the flames of wanting us to fight. I get that
is bothersome for you. You message me behind the scenes and we
don't really resolve anything. What?
what what am I saying, dude? And again, this is me still not
understanding the full depth of how much Nick dislikes me at
this point and thinking he just had this issue with this thing
that happened in May when since June talking about me more robustly
and agreeing with Tommy C >> that was the Aiden leaks.
I should listen to that at some point. I do think that's like
something that's important here is whatever Aiden said about
that. And I would say
I think I already said before I even talked to him that I was
hyperbolic. Oh, you'll do whatever Nick says. I that's hyperbolic.
Okay, that's hyperbolic. I I would take that back for him.
Especially if he leaked this. I was unaware of those leaks. I'm
just like I'm looking at it and I'm seeing things lining up and
I'm like, "Yeah, I think so, man. I think so a little bit."
>> Feels like there are further tensions and pressure,
>> right? Like if he leaks that Nick is going after Tommy
C at the at whatever VidCon,
then that's that's not him like trying to capitulate to Nick
>> to have this conflict. should be fair on >> which
I resist. I try to continue doing >> he's blocked by Nick
again. Unlucky >> my own things outside of EHD slop cycle
which has taken over the commentary space. Alongside that I have
my own outside of streaming. I'm dealing with some issues with
my channel that I'm trying to navigate. Honestly, it feels like
a lot of the communication between us is keeping up appearances.
>> Obviously things have changed and sometimes it feels
like you're just wanting to see if I'm planning on turning on
you. No, you did. You did turn on me. turning on him and saying
you're an Ethan Klein [__]
saying um the big sweep might be on. Look at who does and doesn't
talk about this.
That apparently is turning on him,
bro. I thought turning on him.
I mean,
I think uh how do I put this? What's like fair? Because I think
there's some element here where I do think Chud's like like mad
at Nick or like he thinks like I don't have to sweep for this
anymore. And I'm going to point out the people who I feel like
have to sweep for this a little bit. Right.
I think there's some element some catty element
where it's like it's kind of there's a personal thing there that's
probably why he says the big sweep. That's probably why he does
that. Is that like turning on him? It's like a little catty comment
on the side, right? It's like a little like [__]
you.
He's not like tangibly trying to harm Nick. I I don't believe
that. It's like the banter's got a little further because Nick
just said, "Good luck with whatever you got going on over there
right after like right earlier that day or maybe I don't know
within 24 hours of Chud getting up and covering >> was
doing a queman where you become hyperfixated on him and document
every single thing that he does for months."
I Well, that was dirting on him, but apparently now
>> Yeah. Semaphore. That's That's basically been my case
the whole time is that
Nick had turned on Chud tangibly. So, right. Nick had totally
turned on Chud. Nick was totally trying to stab Chud in the back.
Objectively, objectively, he was that Tommy C stream. I'm sorry.
You don't even need the Aiden leaks to know this. The Aiden leaks
confirm it. So, anybody anybody who is arguing what Becket was
arguing, well, you don't really know that Nick wanted. You don't
really know any of that. You can't say for sure. It's like, yeah,
you can say for sure. And then Aiden comes in and just like proves
that out. He blows out anybody who's trying to argue in the other
direction, right? Yeah. Nick was ready to with this guy. Nick
was down to with this guy apparently. Okay.
So, and I know I'm I'm almost positive Chud would have had like
would have had people telling him that that's the case,
right? It's obvious if Nick's not going to come out and say anything,
it's pretty clear that he doesn't give a [__] about
you. It's pretty clear that he's fine with his name being used
to slander you. So, I I could see him being ready at this point
when Nick's like, "Whatever. Good luck. I'm I'm ready to move
on." They're both kind of bitter about it. I think,
you know, how do you draw the line between f like a you and a
well, I don't have to sweep anymore, so I'm just going to speak
my mind. I don't know. It's really hard. Okay. But in any case,
I wouldn't say it's like a outright betrayal. It's not like Chud
went and said, "Nicholas Dioro, you will never cover this. You're
a total [__] You He like he did a little it was on
the line. >> What I've done is now turning on him and enough
to do all this, you know. So, I'm guessing that like the standards
are getting changed. So, before you know it, just looking at
him the wrong way will justify this sort of treatment. So, watch
out. Watch out anyone that's still associated with Nick. >> Okay,
hold on. We uh I can't even remember where we were on this Chud
react. We broke away into the eight and stuff and then we watched
a little bit of Nicholas Yorio kind of telling a bit of an inconsistent
story and when he got bullied by the protrans YouTube creators.
Okay.
Apparently I do wonder do you think those guys are actually friends
with Boax? It's not like he lives in the same area as them. I
feel like it sounds like those guys were just like you're kind
of an [__] and we saw what you did to this Boax guy.
You're kind of a dick. Maybe was Boax a bit of like a mascot
for a lot of the YouTubers. I feel like that's the impression
I get is Boax was sort of like the kid that people sort of like
bullied but also liked and then they killed him,
right? Like I know Veto liked Boax, didn't like Boax. They thought
he was like a goofy, awkward kid. Was it just that like they
killed him after that and and people sort of resented that? I
wonder >> like I know that Cre's like obviously completely
reliant on me.
I'm crushing with a lot of success. >> So, he's got some
of my cast off. >> Maybe it was >> we've had to have
we've had to kind of edge away some of the pedals. I guess it
was community, >> but maybe we were a bit too boisterous.
Oh, go on. Get out of there. Get out of there.
Anyway, listen. This is the show, >> right? This was us.
So, I'm I'm remembering now the context of this. This was us
going for the the second comment here and watching how Nick reads
it and how Nick tried to read it as Ch being scared of his audience
when it clearly wasn't. Clearly not him saying anything like
that. And that came from this part where we're still watching,
you know, the the >> There was no reason to go after me
whatsoever. I didn't really do anything wrong. We litigated it
not once but twice or it came on stream.
>> Who's the snake again? Who's the snake again, bro? Who's
the [__] snake again? Very obvious.
In spite of this little friendly ending to this little side of
the drama, when there was an opportunity, it was taken to try
and [__] destroy me. And that's that.
So, people saying react to the video. I did react to the video
and I explained everything and point out what a [__]
sensed little [__] he is. Okay, that was a little
bonus. That was a little brucy bonus for you all. Okay,
now let's get back to the video because there are a few more
points to address.
Okay, let's finish polish this off cuz there's a few more points
to address.
>> dude. Is it >> was a bit
information shared with me. >> Regardless, I'm sympathetic
to you getting it from both sides here as well. I don't really
care. In the future, say whatever you want. So, that was the
way that that ended. Now, there's a couple more things that I
do want to address before I'm done tonight. This is a clip that
he just lied to him. >> He just lied here. Let me show
you this >> And then I made some comments about him to
Pisco. Do you remember that?
>> I made it.
>> Actually, when you when you talked about me to Pisco
and said I'm like a sensitive basically and I I likeed you because
you're friends with Queen or something. When you said that, I
was actually mad about that. Wait, wait, no. Hold on. It was
the blocking. I wasn't mad about you saying I'm a sensitive [__]
who blocks people. I was mad that you said I'm a sensitive [__]
who won't be friends with you because of Queenman. That's that's
what he did here. That's the little bait and switch. And it's
like, yeah, Chud might have gotten the nonsubstantive element
wrong, but like substantially he's just talking about how when
you when he talked to Pisco, he said something about you that
implied like wasn't working out. You immediately were in his
DMs account. made some comments to Pisco about how much Nick
blocks people and that I felt. >> So now he's leaning into
his audience's talking points here as if I give a about being
called out for blocking. I've been >> Wait, hang on a sec.
>> That he just responded to him. >> He just lied
here. Let me show you this >> And then I made some comments
about him to Pisco. Do you remember that?
>> I made I made some comments to Pisco about how much
Nick blocks people and that I felt >> So now he's leaning
in. So notice there how much Nick blocks people and pause talk.
But what do I say? What do I say >> into his audience's
talking points here as if I give a about being called out for
blocking? I've been doing this for like seven years. This is
my position. Deal with it. Subscribe. Don't get the out. I don't
really care. But he's trying to lean into the whole blocking
>> Stranged. And guess what? It's strange.
He's trying >> Nick doesn't care about being called a
interesting. Well, it's implied that he's a it's only implied
>> not the same count like I'm saying it's about being
blocked and I say blocked and estranged which is why he messaged
me because I said I felt strang
I was
>> so what the [__] dude >> it's so wild
that he's like it's almost like he's trying to talk over it so
that no one hears it but I do sound strange in that clip
>> I got are you two going to talk to each other the door
is open my end the door is open my end okay I'm happy to talk
to big Nick and and iron all of this [__] out Okay,
it's up to Nick. Balls in his courts. I started getting shared
on social media. >> You got actually nothing because you're
in and leaked the DMs where I told you what I was mad about.
If you actually correlate this clip and what he's saying right
here, I'm talking about how you said that you don't like us anymore
and I'm surprised that you'd say something like that cuz you
ghosted me since September. So, he fabricated this entire angle
that I'm mad about some Pisco conversation. Unfortunately for
Pisco, he's kind of just like, >> "Dude,
I'm
Oh, also he calls Pisco collateral damage here.
What does it mean collateral damage? He was blocked before they
had the conversation. Where's Pisco collateral
Pisco literally says, "Oh, Nicholas Yoro, that guy blocked me
for no
Where was Pisco collateral damage? Why was he collateral damage?
Right. Can you Can you guys think of why Pisco might have been
collateral damage? It's nothing to do with Chud. I feel like
that's a little implied. No. Is that not a little bit implied?
Oh, he skips Pisco saying he was blocked. Interesting.
He was collateral damage. So, you blocked him because he was
collateral damage. Do you think that's because he's adjacent
to Chudlo Logic? No. That doesn't seem reasonable.
Might it be that he's had like actual good tangible push back
to a lot of the stuff that
Ethan's been saying about his own lawsuits that Ethan like called
him out and Pisco said, "Hey, let's talk." and Ethan Ren like
a
>> any stuff like this or is this ringing a bell about
why Pisco might have been collateral damage? Pisco's like a
>> Pisco is like an intelligent good talker. By the way,
I heard Dan was snarking on Pisco a little bit. I might have
to look into that stuff. Okay,
I may have to look in to the Dan snark on Pisco. I heard they
were getting all kinds of mad about Pisco today. Dan Saltman.
Yes, Dan Saltman. Apparently Nicholas Yoru's close friend, Dan
Saltman.
All right. Interesting. More than a little bit. Well, I've heard
about this. I was thinking I should take the night off of covering
that stuff and then come back to it tomorrow.
I think I do want to come back to it tomorrow, but I also I wouldn't
mind taking like a quick look at some of the stuff. I The loner
box thing is what pissed me off though. The lonerbox thing pissed
me off because if you guys Destiny tried to imply, okay, that
I was spreading rumors or something about Lonerbox
um being a over the pixie thing or something. He tried to imply
that when Destiny himself has implied that, I believe multiple
times, at least once, but I believe multiple times.
And it's just not true. And I point out that it's not true. I've
pointed out
that it's not true multiple times, okay? But I think he tried
to do something else today around loader box and it's just it's
such hamfisted
like un
it's it's so hamfisted. It's so goofy. He is
>> I don't get it. He's like so bad at manipulating people
when he's on his back foot. It's very weird. >> Hey, the
point here is I'm speaking to Pisco. There's clearly me talking
to Pisco. I talk about the block and I talk about being estranged
and I get a message from Nick. Okay, he's trying to act like,
"Oh, but I was telling you what the problem was." The problem
is you're messaging me about a clip of me talking to Pisco, dude.
It's so stupid, bro. But yes, I did mention the fact it's because
I felt stranged and I was estranged. You said so in the conversation
and you said that or I found out from this alien story you were
talking about me at VidCon back in June.
>> Like a casualty in this conversation because I >> I
don't know if you guys were here earlier. I did talk about it.
So I think we we kind of
We there've been some chatter on like
>> what are there are a bunch of examples of like Destiny
not not caring about his friends or like negative reputation
harm from his community on his friends and like it is a good
example
right
or just like un unhinged like crazy comments from his own chat
from his own people right
I do think actually Kelly the Kelly Jean thing in November of
sorry 2024 that's Probably the best one, isn't it? The forethought
Kelly Jean thing when when Destiny's literally standing up business.
He's like reading the logs from Forthought. Forthought being
like, "Kelly Gan, I hope your only fans dies so you have to a
dog on camera for the last degenerate viewer you have." He said
some [__] like this, right? Which was tremendously
funny and also incredibly up. Okay, like the level of hate was
tremendously funny, but it was pretty up. And basically people
like, "Hey, Destiny, don't you think it's up that your employees
are saying that to your friends?" Right? Is that not I think
that that was how it was going at the time.
I think the best he could do is go, "Well, she's not really my
friend,
but he totally stood on business on it." I thought I just thought
it was really interesting personally that that he stood on that
and now he's like trying to give Pisco for doing basically the
same thing of being like, "Yeah, but I think like this is important
on principle to stand on this." Like I don't I don't think I'm
on the chat. I think it leads to better conversations if I let
people who are like antagonistic be here and sometimes say things
that I don't believe, but I'm not I'm not necessarily going to
waste time pushing back on. Right. He said some like, "I'm not
going to fire forthought because he says mean to Kelly Jean."
He said something like this. I'm just basically giving Oh, he
said he had the Kelly Gene rule. Right.
Right. And why would anybody have a rule about Destiny? Cisco
has destiny rules to protect him. I guess
really no, they're not. I shouldn't say that. That's like me
being spiteful. They're realistically when he does those rules
that are like don't talk about Destiny drama. Pisco is doing
that to protect himself because if you don't do that, you will
be terrorized. Okay, that's like him buying time. Okay, that's
him giving away the Sudatan land. All right, that's what that's
what Pisco is doing with that rule. He's giving away the It is
appeasement, but he's giving away the Sudatan land and trying
to build up. Okay, trying to have a military build up. >> I
have no issue with him. The issue with the clip that I had is
this one >> recorded against my rules. All right. It wasn't
like anything beyond that. Quean is is Queman like
your friend. >> Well, you tell me, dude. You've spoken
to him more recently on a voice call, apparently. So, you tell
me. >> Well, you're both British. I'm told that Queman
comes from your community. That's what people tell me. >> He
does, but I've had to cast him out because, you know, he's uh
unfortunately been too attack colleagues of mine. He's a Hassan
fan. He's gone after all the commentary guys and they don't like
me >> So, I said it's kind of weird to say that all the
commentary guys don't like you anymore because of Queenman, >> which
this could be multiple people as well, but I wrote back asking,
"Hey,
>> I mean, I think that the reason that Tommy C and Will
don't like me anymore is at least partly to do with the Queenman's
a little vicious Jewish attack dog. You know, I got him on a
leash. You know, they're like Guantanamo Bay prisoners. I got
Queen on the leash. Barking up. Uh, he banned Destiny anyways
and Destiny was not happy. Yeah, I just I didn't get a chance
to see any of it today. I know they would have done their whole
roundup, but unfortunately, like I said, I stayed up to watch
the hockey game. So, when I woke up, actually, I basically had
to start the stream. Is this true that Queman is Wait, hold on.
Hold on. What did he say? >> Guys, and they don't like
me anymore. So I say it's kind of weird to say that all the commentary
guys don't like you anymore because of Queenman, >> which
this could be multiple people as well, but I wrote back asking,
"Hey,
>> I mean, I think that the reason that Tommy C and Will
Mack don't like me anymore is at least partly to do about the
Queenman's a little vicious attack dog. You know, I've got them
on a leash. You know, they're like my Tan Bay prisoners. I got
Creman on a leash bark. But yeah, I mean, is that crazy? Like,
you know, I'm being a bit tug and cheek with it. And I've also
been talking and cheap with the Creamman reference.
>> I mean, how do we put this? So Nick is like totally
Nick's totally cool
with me. And then I say a couple things about Nick that he doesn't
like. He burns a bridge with me. Starts attacking me. Attacks
me. Says, "Oh, you don't know." He He does all of his little
gay attacks. Right.
then
Queman. Oh, sorry. He he attacks me. He uses Kelly Gene to attack
me. Okay. Consistently using Kelly Gene to attack me. Then
Queman starts talking about him and immediately he starts using
me to talk about Quean.
Right. This guy's like not even up. He's not even up enough on
his to give a [__] about
like coming up with good attacks for the people he's currently
upset with. He'll just like try to web them onto somebody he's
in the past in any way he can. Right. So, he starts like trying
to use me to Quimman. He's like attacking me when Quimman like
punches this guy in the face and he turns around and hits me
for some reason. Okay, that's like how it goes for a while. And
then eventually, well, actually, he doesn't really talk back
at Quean, which is very funny. He never he never goes after Chud
with Queenman really which is sort of an interesting break in
that pattern how he's like kind of been trying to do this like
webbing thing and he still really doesn't want any smoke from
Queen or his
So he sort of skips over that one and goes directly back after
Chud again. It is interesting. Okay.
But he is he is like consistently as somebody says something
bad about him and not even like bad as in I'm like totally correct.
This guy's a total loser. I think Queman had some fairly base
like not not incredibly harsh but not
yeah not incredibly harsh criticisms at first. It was the consistent
like downplaying the consistent avoidance that led to Queenman's
criticisms becoming harsher and harsher over time, right? >> Yeah,
I think Queman is probably part of the reason some people don't
like me anymore cuz they associate him with me. >> Why
are you saying that I don't like you anymore considering you've
been ghosting me since September? It's so obvious that this is
what I was saying. It's like verbatim, but if you want to look
at it here, it's
the commentary guys don't like me anymore. So, I wrote you just
ghosted me.
>> So, commentary guys don't like her anymore. He says
to me, you ghosted me. As I've said, he's he's saying here, "Yes,
you're estranged and I've got a problem with you." And on top
of that as well, June comments. So, it's like this this dynamic
where he's saying, "I'm being your friend." It's like, "No, you're
not being my friend. You're doing something else. You're not
being my friend. You said you're not my friend. You said you
had a problem with me. You said privately that I'm I'm fake."
>> That's just crazy. That's insane. Anyway, we get the
point. >> Um, also, yeah, this is just the context of those
messages, too. >> We have we have a lot of subs today,
so like I have I've got more time. I think I'm going to do like
another hour and then I might
>> I don't know if I want to do I don't know how I want
to do this. I probably have to quest and Wow. I'm kind of thinking
about doing Patreon or something. I don't really want to do Patreon
either. I don't know what I'm going to do because I I'll probably
look into that Destiny stuff so I could like find, you know,
the logs and around that to show that he's like obviously lying.
and he's totally disingenuous.
Like I would like to respond to some of that when he's like freaking
out about me or about the situation from two nights ago,
but I I've got to take some time to do that. I'm probably going
to do it while I question. Wow. It's just a matter of >> You
haven't answered me since September because u he hadn't answered
me since September just for your viewing pleasure. Lastly, there's
this clip. >> It's not a safe space. Your friends put a
bot on my server and put my paid Discord on a public website.
>> In this one, I just What the [__] >> Stop
stealing a screenshot. the Discord screenshots now. Stop stealing
his Discord screenshots. >> Now my thing's >> dude.
What the [__] dude? >> This is unbelievable.
>> Oh, what the I was almost done with my thing. Anyway,
all right. So, for that clip, he's telling me that I'm stealing
his screenshots or something. Let me just grab this again. That
sucks. Is it going to reopen? Oh, it reopened. Okay,
Okay, dude. I'm obviously being hyperbolic here, but the idea
that you're going to moan about your Discord, dude, is so wretched,
dude. What happened to this guy, bro? What happened to this guy?
This guy would have thought this was funny before, but now he's
like, "Oh, no. My members Discord.
>> It's not." >> All right, just ignore that.
>> A safe space. Your friends put a bot on my server and
put my fake Discord on a public website. Oh my god, dude. >> So,
he's reading this and he's like, "Nickorio, the guy from the
commentary community is horrified of screenshots." Bro, do you
think that I am embellishing this? Your
maybe not your guy, but I think he might even talking about it
in your server. Some guy created a bot,
put it in my paid server, connected it to a website. This is
not a screenshot. It's a live leak of every message that gets
posted in my feed. >> Dude, he is such a bro. It's not
a screenshot. It's Bro, it's funny, dude. It's funny. I know
it's not funny. It's happening to you and I disavow it really.
I I wouldn't support it. In fact, I think there was some stuff
getting posted. I think I said stop posting that and like said,
you know, I didn't understand what's going on. I was like, "Stop
the boomer mind. I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING. SLOW DOWN.
SLOW DOWN. I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING. Slow down." >> Posting
it, dude. But it's like, come on, dude. Really? You're going
to get pressed about this? It's just, you know, it's funny. It's
funny that like there's some Let's just blast your Discord out
there. And the thing is is like, yeah, sure, sure, sure. Peep
and Sab. Okay. Okay. I'll unban you. I'll unban you.
Do the live leak, bro. It's so >> I I didn't get to the
leaflet stuff again tonight. It's obviously just like a stupid
thing someone's done. Bro, this has got the same energy as when
Ryzen was complaining about Creamman taking his vanity link for
Discord, right? Is that crazy, dude? >> You guys know the
story about that? >> Has Cman told anyone the story about
that? I feel like he's almost certainly made it public. I think
it's it's got to be like public in a way.
I do believe it was I think I was told. Okay. And I I'm sorry
if it's it it can't possibly be something that's like
up to say.
I'm pretty sure it was like DK just for fun. Like Queen server
would go down in boost and you needed like 15 boosts or something
to get the vanity link
and I'm pretty sure
that DK Yeah, he like owed DK money. And so I'm pretty sure DK
paid for like almost all of the boosts on the server so that
they like he literally just spitefully paid for all the boosts
on the server so that they could keep like months and months
and months probably like hundreds of dollars over the course
of all this time
just to be like hey like you in particular man I think that's
I think that's hilarious dude that's a level of hate you bet
DK that spicy would not last six months
Yeah. No, that's Yeah, I think I think that people were posting
stuff that was just like, "Okay, bro." >> That's kind of
like Pisco's channel being dead by the end of the year, right?
Isn't Pisco's channel supposed to be dead by the end of the year
or something? I've heard this. Has anyone else heard this? Have
we heard about this? Have you seen this? >> Like that seems
a bit like excessive. And then I think the reason you got banned
is I questioned it and you were like, "Oh, hack it." And I was
like, "Right, [__] Get the out, dude. We're not playing
games with this." You know, classic classic Discord antics. We'll
take it too far. But I think we said like, "Yeah, got stop posting
this, dude. It's ridiculous." It's not even like I supported
it, dude. It's just funny that Nicholas is seething about >> The
server of all my paid members supporting my channel. I don't
care if if you're screenshot >> support for Nicholas Dioro's
private Discord server is crucial right now.
>> It like a Okay, whatever. >> They are mirroring
my entire server. And you know, you know who knew that? Well,
Chud here because he's reading a message where I verbatim say
it. Now, this was inevitably taken down. >> Here's the
thing.
I was shown some information by Dan. You guys probably remember
this.
Oh, my headphones. But did I? Um, you probably remember this.
Dan like came on stream and was like, "No, you you you don't
understand. Dan Clansancy is going to be gone." And he showed
me some stuff
and it's like
I think I can kind of hint. I'm not going to leak it, but I can
kind of hint it was like big commitments from big companies to
stop advertising on Twitch. It was like a lot of money that he
said like we've got these commitments already provably leaving
Twitch. A lot of money.
And I don't understand if that's the case. If they lost like
that much advertising money, I don't understand how Dan Clansancy
wasn't fired to be honest with you.
I do think that it probably wasn't commitments. Maybe they didn't
last that long or maybe the the money was already leaving something.
>> But woo. Awesome. Uh, I think Aiden spread like a rumor
that I was trying to sue the guy who did it. I don't know if
this is like a [__] position or what. I I don't own
Discord. I can't sue you for putting my members server on a website.
That's stupid. I just wanted it down because that's kind of crazy
and it's like a like are we going to start like individually
parsing the guys who give me money next? Is that the next thing
that we're going to do because you guys hate me that much? Is
that the plan? Like what's what's >> bro? So hyonic, bro.
Dude, this guy is like hysterical. He's hysterical, dude. >> Going
on here. So I was like, "Yeah, dude. Oh, you're in a safe space
on Discord." I'm not in a safe space. You dude, your fans are
doing this.
Stop stating a screenshot. >> Can I just ask, do we think
Nick's in a good place where he's making good decisions?
Didn't
he is a dick, but didn't Nick after the Malta event with Aiden
say Aiden was totally untrustworthy?
Aiden is totally untrustworthy because of the Perry thing, which
by the way, I don't even think is necessarily true. Like maybe
you could argue sharing a room with Perry makes you untrustworthy.
But Aiden kind of got his privacy violated. Kind of. He absolutely
got his privacy violated, right?
So like he but he said Aiden's totally untrustworthy. Unblock
him on everything. And then for some reason he unblocked Aiden.
He started reaching out again. He started trying to rebuild that
friendship. Doesn't that give you an impression of like how concerned
Nicholas is? like in his in the back of his mind, he's like really
worried that
they're like wolves at the door right now. That Aiden's the guy
that he's going to go and be like, "Dude, I can't believe this
is happening. I can't believe they're they're all they're copying
my Discord. They're copying my disc." Like, did he not have other
people? Where are all of his guys?
He's guyless.
He's He ain't got no guys. All his guys
are the people who would have asked like, "Hey, this this H3
seems weird, right? This H3 seems weird. By by."
And so he reaches out to Aiden because I think he
Well,
I'm going to say I think my perception of Aiden was probably
aligned with what Nick's perception of Aiden was, which may be
incorrect. Okay. based on the leaks that Aiden's done. I'm going
to keep saying maybe Aiden's not uh what do you call it? Um
replaceable. What was the word he used? Disposable. Maybe Aiden's
not disposable. But I can't believe that Nick Nick has said multiple
times by his own account, Aiden's not trustworthy. And then he
goes to the guy he says is untrustworthy and says a bunch of
things he probably wouldn't want leaked.
I I just wonder why that's what Tommy C says. Oh god, is this
another Tommy C is right moments?
>> that's that's just what Nicholas needs. Tommy C in one
of his group chats or DMs going, "Well, Nick, I told you that
Aiden was shifty. I said it all along that Aiden was shifty.
I told you this would happen, Nick. I told you this would happen."
>> Steing his Discord's great shots. >> He's got
it in front of him and he just lies to you. He just lies to you.
>> He just lies. He's lying to you. Sadly, you're right.
>> He's just lying to you. No, bro. I'm laughing at you,
okay? I'm laughing at you expressing it in a funny way that you're
seething about some stupid bot that logs your Discord
and I'm referring to it as a screenshot cuz that's the format
that I'm getting it in. But come on. No, actually, you don't
understand. It's not just a screenshot. It's actually a very
sophisticated bot. All sophisticated. Watch out for that word.
That logs all the messages in my Discord
>> to your face straight away. So, that's the Oreo rodeo.
And then this is the last thing. Unfortunately, this is the only
thing that I can't prove to you definitively because it's entirely
fabricated. It just didn't happen. But I will preface something.
This is what I'm going to say about this allegation. >> This
one after having been subjected to some deranged [__]
attack against my credibility whilst I'm on holiday and I'm the
spineless one apparently. What the [__] How about
addressing the questions people are asking instead of just calling
them? What do you mean I'm addressing the questions, dude? >> I'm
sorry. I I was trying to pull up the clip that I wanted, but
I got more of him yelling at his shot. I'm sorry, dude. I'm sorry.
I I actually didn't mean to do this. Yeah, this is obviously
an alien concept for Nick. He's banned anyone that might disagree.
So, he doesn't interact with his chat like that. He just pumps
out whatever the
has done yesterday to his army of Julia just sit there and clap
like seals. Whereas, I get a bit of push back and I have to roll
the punches a little bit with my
>> Chud, this is cold. Chud, this is cold. Chud Chud, find
something good. Chud, find something good. Chud, find something
good.
Dude,
I do wonder just how whipped the community is for Nicholas. I
should like watch a stream at some point and just watch the the
I feel like when I've watched the chat in the past,
they obviously miss everything.
Like I watch my chat pretty often cuz my chat's perceptive. Okay,
a lot of in this chat who catch little details. All right,
Nick's chat. Nick's chat is just like barely cognizant. Barely
barely conscious. Okay, conscious. God, I always say conscience
instead of conscious
every single time. They're barely conscious. Okay, they're like
out of it. They're zoned out. They've got their
They've got their anti-anxiety meds. They got their glass of
wine. They're just listening to this guy laugh and and and smiling
slightly. They don't even clap like seals. They're barely awake
enough to clap like seals. Okay. There's like
That's right. Ethan's awesome.
An is a
[__] me up. I didn't mean to put more. >> Thank
you for the super chat. Thank you, >> dude. He's got to
stop being so sensitive, man. >> Very good. Very good.
Didn't you also signal boost the Assan crews cancel culture al?
This is clearly not what I wanted. Hold on. Let me just get it
quick. I know where to find it. Um,
if we can grab it. What the What the What happened? Why are we
full screen, bro? I'm I'm I'm a professional streamer. I promise
you.
This stream went so well up until the very last second for non-scripted
people. So, >> show the clip. Link the clip. Start. Come
on. I'm lazy. So, the past 1:00 a.m., man, on the last conversation,
somewhat amicable at the end and it seemed like maybe it was
kind of resolved or, you know, at least not going to continue
on. But then when I'm on holiday, the video comes out and Nicholas
does this attack against me, which then leads to all of this
when I come back. I'm not saying that Tom was sat there thinking
I'm going to wait until, you know, Ch's on holiday. It's more
so like Nicholas recognizes an opportunity
to get the boot into me whilst I'm away and it just so happens
to line up in that direction.
The last day that you know the first day that I'm off that drops
and then all the Oh, you're sweeping but I'm covering that [__]
comes in.
Come on.
>> And we were like BWC you're dropping on >> I feel
like so I didn't watch all Chud's stream there. It felt like
he leaned into it. Now maybe you just say he leaned into it because
these guys they leaned into a bunch of wrong [__]
about
I don't know, but it it did feel like >> when are you going?
I think I'm gonna drop mine on Tuesday. Okay, you you drop on
Tuesday, Tom. I'll drop on Wednesday. Uh because I used that
information he gave to film an interview at Colossal and Slaza
to debunk it before they even put it out. Bob Blacks, Twitter
versus on Thursday. Everyone, we're going to go to Auggie on
Friday. Uh that was the most coordinated thing the commentary
community has ever done. But the reason why we did it is because
he was bragging about how much fun he was going to have in Los
Angeles. So, we wanted to his vacation. So, we put a video out
every single day. So, what Vegas is talking about where he's
like, "Yo, did you see Nick just dropped the video?" That was
like the second bomb. You can go ask anybody who was in VidCon
2019. They'll tell you there was a story where I'm Alex is walking
around with a thousand yard stair like a bomb just went off and
he's like what is going on? He's just walking around the party.
Ask Willie. Apparently, he bought him a beer and then put out
a video called I'm Alex is the biggest douchebag when he got
off the plane when he got home. >> I remember I remember
um I think it was like Nick, you dropped the first video and
then I had one and then you dropped the interview I want to say
is the way. >> No, the interview was my video. Um >> was
it Did you have a video like before that that was about it without
the >> That was before I met Alex, but that was like a
that was like a month earlier, right? you went and you dropped
the first video, I dropped my video, and then you dropped a follow
up on Hiojin when she started dating.
>> So, yeah, like I say, I'm not saying that Tom was like,
I'm going to I'm so scared of Ch and his 50k subs. It's that
Nicholas had a convenient opportunity to line it up in a way
that he could get his jabs in on me. And do you see now, especially
seeing that last conversation, why I'm so blindsided? Because
Tom's response doesn't change anything about what I've said.
I've said, I don't really think the allegations got much merit.
there's problems with them and blah blah blah. Age based stuff.
I got the most legs and he responded terribly to that. But anyway,
you know, right? So, when I'm going away, I obviously don't know
Tom's going to respond. And also, even if Tom does respond, I
don't think there's going to be some attack against me because
it's like, well, I've covered it fairly. But it's engineered
in a way allegedly
the allegation drops. Nick starts getting the booting on the
sweeping stuff and then he starts talking about me more on stream.
And then I get back and I respond. I leak a few DMs.
Nicholas then leaks the M of response and I leak a few more and
I leak a little bit more. Oh, dude. Anyway, let's finish this.
>> Not trying to get out of it. I'm not trying to hide
anything. It's just not what happened. Unfortunately, it would
be really funny if it was true because that would mean that Chud
Logic went on vacation for two weeks, which is identical to the
amount of time that I couldn't respond to Chud Logic without
over my friendship with Turkey Tom because Turkey Tom still had
>> Yeah, Nick pretended to be a good sport in a Tea Party
chat when he was still unsure whether Tom was ready or not. Yeah,
I think that was before there was like a knowledge of the video.
The video I think was seen by them on the 27th. That's the other
thing as well. The video was ready on what the 27th. I think
there's a message of Nicholas talking about the video being being
ready on the 27th just in case more stuff came out. They held
it back and then it was released unchanged the day after I went
away
>> responding to his allegations. So it is very funny.
Um and it is very funny that it happened while Ch was on vacation
and I wish I thought of it but I didn't. >> So that's my
position on that >> video being being ready on the 27th
just in case more stuff came out. They held it back and then
it was released unchanged. Maybe I'm insane. >> They are
sure I went away
>> responding to his allegations. So, it is very funny.
Um, and it is very funny that it happened while Ch was on vacation.
And I wish I thought of it, but I didn't. So, that's my position
on >> I wish I thought of it, but I didn't. Probably to
get too too hung up on the language there.
Sorry. It's just like
it's just when he says, "I didn't think of it." That's not saying
it didn't happen.
And you're not. And I feel like at the start of it, he was like,
"Turkey Tom
would never risk anything
like this. That would be crazy." And it's like, "Okay,
well, I don't think it was a risk." One, I don't think it was
a risk when you hold it
when you hold it. But I I just don't think Nicholas Nicholas
I can't see him lying. Or sorry, I can see him lying. I can't
see him lying poorly like that. Like I it does it does sort of
line up, but why not just lie there? Why not just lie? Just lie,
right? Like I don't see him doing the half lie with the speaking
around it in case logs get released. If the logs get released,
you're kind of there. So I don't know what sort of half thing
he could be doing here.
I feel like you just lie. So I don't I don't think the English
is like an indicator. You could still say they planned it if
you believe that. I don't really care. But I I was like listening
to the English and I'm like, "Oh, that sounds weird." >> But
I don't know. I don't think Nick is like that kind of a that
he's like, "Well, I don't want to lie. I'm just going to like
I'm just going to like kind of step around it." >> You
can believe it or not believe it, but ultimately if it was true,
I'd be okay with it. It just didn't happen that way. Turkey Tom
was getting accused of a various amount of things. You can go
read the Kiwi Farms thread. Uh Sacramento just kept going all
weekend long. That is likely the reason why the video didn't
get released on the planned whatever day was actually going to
come out because when you keep drip feeding things, you don't
know if you're going to have to make three videos or one video.
The intention is to make one definitive video. And I think any
reasonable person would come to that conclusion, but Chud Logic
is not a reasonable person. >> As planned,
>> he's almost as unhinged as Ymss. No, dude. Chud Logic
goes to this
to this [__] Vietnamese brothel, okay? Every single
year, his fans know that he goes to this trans Vietnamese >> Wait,
I don't even understand. I don't think that framing makes any
sense either. They're holding off like that,
right? Does that even make sense?
Again, I don't care. I don't I don't care. I'm not going to say
I thought they held it back or something. I don't think so.
Although, I would like to ask Auggie again if I ever talk to
him again. We'll see. But like, okay, you've categorically like
blown out two of the major allegations.
Like, you you've totally blown them out and the person
I I just don't see why you wouldn't release that video. That
video like totally damages all of their credibility. That video
could go out as is. to hold it for like multiple extra days when
there have been no additional allegations. That doesn't really
make sense to me
>> every single year, dude. To tell you the truth, stupid
Rob's media has come out. I'm I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. It's a joke.
It's a joke. It's a joke. I make a Ymss joke. >> You sound
mad.
>> it's YMS's stupid movie convent. Sorry. Sorry. Right,
dude. Current Nick just jumped over retro 2022 Nick Dioro. My
bad. I Current Nick just jumped out of me. Sorry.
I think it's just frustrating really. It's just frustrating to
>> I thought Tom waited to put the video out because you
wanted the girls to put everything they had up before he responded.
Um I mean, you know, that could be true from Tom's end.
I just think that the fact that nothing was changed from the
27th when Nicholas watched it and then it was delayed apparently
to do that and then it just happened to line up in a way that
meant the boot could be gotten to me without be able to spawn
instantly or because obviously I could have um from their perspective
maybe streamed. The thing is, by the time I was on my way, right,
I thought if I stream about this, I'm just going to be wrapped
up in [__] this drama for the first part of the trip.
And I thought, you know what? I'll just deal with it when I'm
back. I'll just deal with it when I come back. So, I just uh
you know, I did check in a bit and just saw a little bit of the
scuttle butts and then my phone ran out of battery, my work phone.
I used two phones. I was like, I was getting another coffee and
chill for the rest of the trip. Anyway, that's my perspective
on it to witness such cowardice. >> So, yeah, this is it.
Tread Logic leaked a DM that had no context because his chat
bullied him bullied him into it and then I had to provide the
rest of the content that I was perfectly fine with kind of just
letting go until he decided to shank me in the back minutes after.
>> Shank me in the back. >> I think this is just
really I think it's really dude why is this different than all
of the other I was reading through the Reddit post and people
were like, "Dude, Chad does this to Nick all the time. Why is
this one different?" It's like, "Yeah, because you think I'm
an >> All Chad to do is per three-minute vid the day Turkey
made his vid say my bad. No, that's incorrect though. That would
be incorrect because I had nothing to apologize for. I hadn't
said that the allegation was definitively true and everyone was
trying to spin it like that in order to smear me to make me look
less credible and then all of this has happened now.
>> Defender sweeper.
>> Sure. That's like a really that's like a language. So
ultimately what what does this mean? What does this mean for
the channel? After this, we're going back to covering trending
news coverage. Uh this community is gonzo. No remorse. Same thing
I said during the salvo edwin stuff. Uh I'm never talking to
Chloic >> Wow. They just like salvo.
>> Just like Yeah. Uh, [__] you, Chud. [__]
you, you [__] I was about to say that. [__]
you, man.
They're just like, he's just like these other people that are
really bad to my whole audience. Hey guys, he's just like Salvo
and Edwin and Bob Blacks and Flamco and every bad guy ever.
And I think warranted. I think that's a warranted position that
I'm having. Um, and yeah, that's that's probably the last time
I will ever address this. The first and last time. It's nice.
It's wrapped in a bow. And you'll see the segment tomorrow. Uh,
[__] this guy. The community that controls this guy,
his friends, his family, [__] the entire Great Britain
as a whole. I'm I should have known better than to trust an English
YouTuber. >> This guy seems genuinely upset, dude. What
the
>> I'm crying, bro. Ain't that serious,
>> Uh, I respected this guy immensely. The way that he
navigated his Destiny drama to defend DK editing, I thought he
was one of the most principled people I've ever interacted with.
I was clearly wrong. This guy totally sucks and this is why I
hate Chud Logic. So ladies and gentlemen, I don't even know how
many of you are. >> Now listen, I will be fair. I know
all people in Chad I'm not watching this gay video anyway guys.
There we go. There we go. There we go guys.
That
is it. That is it. Hope you enjoyed that. I had fun. I had fun
day.
Oh man. >> Oh dude, that was funny, wasn't it? That was
a funny stream.